Nah day.
None of that.
Come on.
Sorry man.
Yeah,
we're live.
All right.
Fight Day folks.
A fight companion podcast.
If you listen to this podcast and say,
Oh,
here's another pot,
what does a fight companion podcast if I companion podcast,
the podcast that we do while we're watching the UFC.
So if you're tuning into it,
what it's like is it's like you're watching the fights with friends that you
don't really know,
but they go.
So Brendan Schaub is here,
Ladies and gentlemen,
the fucking big Brown in the house.
Brian Calendar here,
ladies.
Gentlemen.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Can't wait.
I've got to learn.
Of course.
Edgy Bra.
Also known as Eddie Bravo.
That's what they taught when we were in Brazil.
That's the calling the hey is Joe Moran.
Were those the first giant tournament that there was an la Joe,
my analyst,
he was the main promoter and in my division that was 45 guys were all blue belts
and my division,
he's,
and you got to sit there and listen to him.
Call out everyone's name and I'm sitting there,
I'm waiting for him to call.
My name is,
he looks,
he looks at the clipboard,
then he looks up,
here's your bra.
I'm standing right in front of him.
I'm like,
man,
when are they going to call my dad?
Like fuck.
And then someone say,
dude,
I think he's saying your name.
No Way.
I could never guess your nationality by the way.
I'm looking at you right.
Ever.
So it was just in Mexico and I was leaving and he had to go through Mexican
customs and the guy looked at my passport just today.
He looked at my passport.
It says Edgar,
I'd bet at the Bravo,
he looks at it.
Duet is Latino.
I go and I had to speak Spanish.
My Spanish sucks,
but I can say I see I'm going to spit on me,
papayas,
the Chihuahua and my mother.
They one of the hotter,
I can say that back.
It sounds like I speak really good Spanish.
I got that mastered.
I've said that a million times.
I got that shit wired.
So I sat that and he was convinced and my shit,
you look,
you look like you look tie.
Let's be honest.
[inaudible]
man.
He could definitely,
it can definitely be like some like ex pat,
he had went over there with PTSD 100% awesome growing up.
Unfortunate Tyler
Filipino.
Remember when the fee they shipped the Filipinos in?
In the,
in the 80s sure.
Shit man.
But I was born in,
does anybody know these guys?
Um,
Sean Strickland who we're looking at right now.
Yeah.
I was hitting himself a few days acute in Santiago.
Got His name blocked off.
Good job.
UFC fucking website designers.
He's in a different point.
The guy's head in front of his fucking name.
20th Yeah.
Santiago.
Well you've seen his points.
He need to be a Ponzi Niebuhr.
Is he from Brazil?
Everyone is going to be a,
like a lot of people from Brazil because this card is live from Brazil.
So if you're,
if you're tuning in and you're trying to figure out how the fuck do we sync it
up because the internet is always going to be a few seconds slower than live
action.
So what we're seeing and what you're,
you're seeing,
it's going to be a little different.
So pause your TV.
That's the best way.
Pause your TV and like maybe counted 10 and I'm going to tell you exactly when I
see five minutes on the first round.
It's about to start now.
It says four 58 right now.
45074506455 there you go.
All right.
We're sinked up ponds,
an Ebu and Strickland.
Remember there was only three or four Brazilian fighters and now there's
hundreds of thousands.
Do you know how many fighters are in the UFC roster now?
They guess,
uh,
1100 8,500 yeah,
he's right.
500 wow.
Isn't it insane?
What?
500 yeah.
And that really ponds and Nivo with a right hand that expanded that Joe's
stricken one.
The Nice uppercut.
How do they have fun?
I thought they had like maybe a hundred people on the roster period.
No,
no.
They've had a few hundred for a while.
They've had like two 5,300 but now you know also I think that with Bella tour
out there,
they'd got to make sure they scoop up the young talent as it's coming up.
Cause would have Bella tour gets a hold of John Jones before the UFC does and
they got some guy over there and just rag doll in people and John Jones in them
and you go,
Oh fuck we missed that guy.
You remember probably like two years ago when they were making crazy cuts
because they had to get rid of a hundred guys like sort amount of time.
Dudes are just getting [inaudible] guys.
Well John Fitch got cut.
Oh left big left hook by ponds and Nivo Strickland.
Very experienced man.
Look at him.
Hang on.
Very smart.
Yeah.
You know how they showed the records?
15 to know and the other guy's 20 and two.
You really don't know guys records these days.
Why do you say that?
Uh,
I cause I feel like inbox and you look more at records.
I feel like
cares about
like you know the stars.
I was confused.
I thought you were saying like they might not,
you might,
they might.
It might be a bullshit record.
No,
no,
no.
You're saying most people don't know.
You just know.
I don't know anybody.
Like I couldn't tell you.
Oh yeah.
When you're a boxing fan you have to know everybody's record.
Yeah.
24 knock,
right?
Had the fuck.
Nah,
he got to know everybody in the top 10.
It was just,
did you go to that?
Open up the buck and open up ring and go right to the standings like top 10 of
every division.
I would just stare at that shit and try to memorize it.
Did you guys see Gennady Golovkin last month?
Triple G.
He's up to these guys.
It's three g's.
What's the third g great.
Gennady Golovkin is that it?
No,
I think that three g I think in uh,
he's from a Cogeco.
Stan [inaudible] Stan.
But what is it when it isn't that kind of fended still get a bed.
[inaudible]
like you're headed idiot.
Who's like giving a speech in front of his class.
I looked up at the sky when I said it.
Oh,
this is why you're wearing a scarf,
by the way,
because I'm French.
I'm keeping my preset.
Your wife dressed you before got here.
That's a lie.
I don't want to say,
I just think it's cashmere.
It's a cashmere.
His cashmere neck right here.
It's made out of the awkward pumps and evils in trouble,
man.
Strictly and I've not stopped looking at his hair.
I'm really attracted to him.
I mean it's Megan,
this motherfucker work.
I'll tell you that.
It's to keep some mixing up from punches to take downs.
He's putting a lot of pressure on this guy.
I'm not tall.
Polish strict.
Right.
He could be anything American.
Yeah.
I think it'd be from Georgia.
He can be French.
I hate to tell you he could be from France.
He could be from Czechoslovakia if won't say he kicked me out.
My last name,
like [inaudible] chick,
like,
Hey,
he'll Honda jet jet check.
I think getting out of go up against from Kurdistan.
Oh,
it'd be right.
did you watch the fight though?
I didn't watch it.
I was,
I seen him last night floor.
Yeah.
I love that.
I love that guy.
Oh,
head kicked by ponds and Ebo.
Everyone wants to see him.
Verse Andre.
Warden that.
Oh yeah,
that's a great fight.
I don't think Andre Ward's going to take it.
Why would he take it Coleville of you?
Me and her are no Andre Ward.
Hold on.
Look what's going on.
Evo.
Going off.
Girl.
Fucking Duran over here.
Crazy.
Five fingers in the neck to look like he's going crazy.
Fuck.
Oh,
that was a hard right hand isn't woke his ass up.
Yeah.
I don't know what it is,
but there's a minute to go and he's still fucking going at it.
It's like rocky Graziano man.
I can't hear the crowd by,
but they're going nuts.
It was a good one.
Grounds.
Most Yanno little volume on the TV commercial on Jamie.
Hey,
fuck.
What were we just talking about?
Yeah,
why don't we take that?
Because I don't,
because we know triple g,
but I don't think triple g's that big of a star.
The triple t make all sold a lot.
Like he's not,
he's not.
No,
It's shut the fuck up cause Kovalev was the one who is going to find you're out
of your 160160170 five that's three different weight classes.
They all right.
Andre Ward one 68 Golovkin one 60 called 1175 [inaudible] 75 were you guys
talking about boxing?
Oh really?
I thought he's applied to every way.
Yeah.
He wants to fight Miguel Cotto that's what he wants.
Kovalev does.
No,
Andre Ward does.
Triple g wants to fight.
You guys are really into boxing like yeah man.
You know what?
I should probably say that on the podcast because a bunch of people asked me,
cause I,
a long time ago I'd gotten this debate on ESPN with that fucking Lou Dibella
guy.
The only reason why I went on that guy like that to raise one is UFC wanted me
to play too.
They sicked me all this guy cause they knew this guy talks a lot of shit about
the UFC and he just started doing all the dos Joe.
Yeah.
Joe Goes,
I guess on that interview juggles.
The fact is that boxing is getting swallowed.
It's getting swallowed.
He's getting smelled by more dynamic sport,
you know?
But I've always been a boxing fan,
just like I'm a kickboxing Fran,
just like I'm a straight Jujitsu fan.
I'm a fan of Walmart,
fan of dummies.
No lobbying.
Told me you know a lot about what's going on in boxing.
Oh yeah.
All I know is Matt packing.
Alan Floyd Mayweather going to find me,
said I'm going to make $1 billion.
Well go off gets old enough.
Fascinating guy because he's one of the best fighters in the world and very few
people know who he is.
That's the side of like hardcore MMA fans.
Everybody knows who Floyd Mayweather is.
Everybody knows who Manny pack Yo is.
Those are the two guys.
But Gennady Golovkin is a fucking murderous puncher.
I mean body shots like guy.
Yeah,
he's from Russia.
Beautiful Cutie little handsome fella.
He looks like he looks like guys in the mix with these Floyd Mayweather.
Russians,
man.
So fear of is also Russian
punchers call them.
Margins are still good right now.
Dude.
If Vladimir demands and beaten been beaten in 10 years,
not even close these letters best.
There's no really good heavyweights.
We can destroy you don't you don't hear about,
but he's like years ahead of him about these fights because his fights are so
dominant and he's boring.
He boxes them.
He just jabs him to death.
I love it.
Is Gray whale watches I watch in the biggest,
strongest,
fastest and can touch him.
That Russian dude native go to show that Russia duty fought,
made him go to war that first round.
He got dealt with them finding the best black dudes.
Yeah.
He fights.
He fights his next fight and he is a black guy.
Let's just be honest about some shit.
Russians are different white people.
Okay.
They just different white Siberia,
I don't want to say a tougher,
tougher.
Their environment is tougher.
They live in a harsher climate.
Their history is tougher.
They have a war torn history did.
They were conquered by the Mongols for 200 plus fucking years.
You know,
that's a hard Siberian climate and the country's flat and Mongo is telling me
you have a flag concern.
The Asian Chinese looking guys were ruling over the white guys in the north.
A lot of people in Russia,
in certain parts of Russia,
look Chinese.
That's right on the border.
Yes.
I think I understand that.
But to say
we can't talk at the same time,
that's why we're wearing headphones boys.
Huh?
Day ahead of us.
As far as technology to science,
Russia,
no,
no.
We're American.
Not Anymore.
I think at nine it's from Kazakhstan and in that area you do see a lot of,
cause I can townies who look very Asian,
way more Asian and Caucasian.
Where's Kovalev looks,
he's Caucasian,
he's Caucasian and he'd go off,
go off,
can looks like a mix,
but he's a cute looking guy.
Like he could be like the suite next door neighbor on a s,
maybe even the gay neighbor.
I'm on a Sitcom,
right.
That's his buddy comes in and just liver punches you and do fucking oblivion.
He's a sensational boxer and he's a highly aggressive,
well,
he,
he's special because he has knockout power in his left hand and right hand.
You know,
certain guys have certain branches to knock people out.
Yeah.
He's not guys out with jabs.
Left hooks,
right.
Hooks,
uppercuts.
Yeah.
I saw a highlight clip.
He dropped the do with the right hand to the body.
It's ridiculous.
Just he's hitting people so fucking hard.
But America doesn't care.
Micar won't jump on board unless you can be good in front of a camera.
Well,
dude,
if the,
if you,
when I was a kid,
if someone came along and told me that we were going to have a white heavyweight
champion that no one would give a fuck about and no one could beat the guy,
I'd be like,
that doesn't even make sense.
Like what kind of bizarro world we live in it and saying,
wait a minute,
he's fighting the best guys dominant now when I can't,
when I was totally into boxing,
you never heard of such a thing.
Dude,
he's got a p Gerry Cooney.
Remember Gerry Cooney,
he's brilliant.
He's got a phd.
Like,
he's a brilliant guy.
He plays chess.
So let's Tex Cobb,
what did that get up?
Let me ask you this.
Jermaine Taylor,
is that his name?
Tremaine Taylor.
Yeah.
He's all fucked up now too.
That's old school that's doing all kinds of crazy violence shit like outbursts.
Pull a gun on punchbowl.
Got arrested.
Risk Cup.
I'm sorry,
not your main Taylor.
Who was the guy the big,
the guy would just beat wilder.
Yes.
Yeah.
How would he do against,
he's gonna is he gonna fight it?
He's not ready.
He'll,
he'll be ready.
Have,
I mean,
he might be ready.
He might be able to catch them.
The thing about Klitschkos Klitschko has been knocked out back in the day when
he first started working with Emanuel steward or right before he first started
working with the manual.
You went to a man who hasn't been touched and he,
uh,
when he went to a manual,
a manual just completely schooled him,
cleaned his game up,
and Emanuel Steward said he's the hardest righthand puncher he's ever seen in
his life.
Wow.
Now's the guy had Lennox Lewis and just stable took different white people.
You know what a manual it says,
he said it like Joe Jelly.
I beep number Gabet off.
That's a different kind of white person.
That's a different way.
Person that Charles and cock sucker.
This I'm not the same white pippy you fucking grew up with in Calabasas,
but you're fucking [inaudible] away.
Get Out of your range rover.
Just suck his dick.
He's going to kill everybody.
Fight.
Yeah,
that's a good fine Strickland cause a good grappler.
Ah,
I'm gonna get a Mohawk.
I think it's like a Hari Krishna thing.
The ones we've lost the hair pony.
He lost the ponytail and came up in the fight.
That's how bad dudes want pussy.
They're profilers and they still grow their hair.
That covers over their eyes.
I know.
I appreciate it.
Hey,
if I had beautiful hair and my growth,
I always told when I fuck it.
Hixon when he was young,
I had this Crazy Samurai ponytail and it was like part of his mystique when he's
this Samurai warrior going into new is tattered black belt that almost look
white because it was so worn and just show strangling.
True lines of dudes.
Just get them in a lie and line them up one at a time and roll them up.
Shit.
Yup.
Roll them up like it's nothing.
Never get,
never get out of breath.
Tap One guy after the next.
It's still a handsome devil.
He's seen him label man.
We had him on Saturday and acted.
Just look sexy with bangs and some people don't.
Yeah,
I never had.
You never have to.
I keep my eyes.
Keep him out of my eyes.
You're a rugged guy though.
You gotta be ready for action in a moment's notice.
Thanks buddy.
I appreciate the fucking pig hunt we're going on with Steven Rinella.
Got To get my license.
We'll do that.
Let's do that this week.
You in town this week you're going to go kill a pig.
Fuck down and when to to hone ranch up north.
Wild been going there with Cameron Hanes.
We're going to Sacramento.
Ooh,
that's where we're going.
It's up in that area.
I don't think so.
I think we're using rifles.
They have an infestation.
Oh yeah.
Northern California has literally has a pig infestation and a lot of it.
Yup.
Well,
in neighborhoods,
San Jose News,
the other day they had this,
uh,
this news clipping of these wild pigs were tearing up these people's lawns in
the suburbs.
I'd make him just ripping the,
I'm ripping the lawn apart,
looking for something to eat.
And they're pretty gnarly.
Right.
Like the,
for a kid that's incredible.
For California and Fresno,
there's a big problem and it's that weird San hose
and like a real issue.
Oh yeah.
It's real issue.
But you know,
that's great.
I'm hunters.
We have,
uh,
a huge,
I don't know if it's a problem,
but we got raccoons everywhere at families of raccoons,
little babies traveling together,
coming to try to open our door screen door.
I go,
Babe.
Oh Shit.
It's trickling on top.
Swarming on them.
Yeah.
I mean the pig problem is mitigated slightly by the fact that they're not
allowed to hunt from mountain lions.
Some mountain lions eat some of the pigs.
I was going to say what's their natural predator?
That's it.
Just no,
there's no natural predator.
They're not from here.
They're Eurasian wild boars there.
The a long time ago,
they believe that a lot of them came from William Randolph Hearst
when we ran off.
Hearst had that Hearst castle up in northern California.
That crazy fuck kept a bunch of wild boars out there,
man.
And a lot of them got loose tanks hers and then they just run up fucking and
breeding.
And then of course on top of that there's just wild pigs,
domestic pigs that you know became Pharell and they start breeding out in the
wild and then they become a totally different kind of pig.
But there's so many of the northern California,
you could shoot as many as you want.
You could go like,
you could get all your meat from pigs and just go up there like once every
couple months,
shoot four or five pigs,
bring them back with you.
And it doesn't cost very much to get a pink tag,
so it should be easy to kill him up.
Yeah.
Got to take out some of these pigs.
I killed him.
I killed one of the first day we went.
Really?
Yeah.
I kill the pig.
It was like it got dark at five o'clock I killed the pig at four 15 I just liked
that.
It's not going to be freezing this.
Why don't we just go up there?
Some machine guns do a gangster style.
You could do it that way on the copter.
I don't think there's any restriction.
They use it from a helicopter in Texas.
In Texas.
They have these shows about them where they are.
It's crazy.
You think that's all Henry Rollins do it right now?
Ted Nugent.
The opposite.
That's right.
My bad.
Just some loud white guy.
Yeah,
right,
but yeah,
they do it out of helicopters.
They call it a pork lips.
Now is the most fucked up thing to watch up there were colliding it just gunning
down these packs of pigs in Fresno.
This is Texas in Texas.
They allow them to hunt with Halifax.
They cost millions.
Reminds me neither.
I'm scared there's,
there is millions of feral pigs in California.
Dom million.
I haven't seen,
you know what else,
what else did William Randolph Hearst cause like he caused the peg problem but
the wheat problem.
Yeah.
He was also responsible for weed being illegal.
He's a whoa head kick.
He was responsible for distributing the propaganda and even possibly risk one of
the people responsible for using the name marijuana.
So it was like a real asshole or you have chosen that because of dupont and
there as well as well as his,
uh,
paper factories apparently.
But,
uh,
I mean that's the reason why William Randolph Hearst was the subject of a,
that Orson Welles movie.
I mean that was the whole Rosebud citizen Kane.
It's about William Randolph Hearst.
William Randolph Hearst was a gangster when you had control of the newspaper
back when there was only one newspaper kill me.
God Damn.
It's like is we're running stories.
They were running stories.
I like that one store where woman smokes weed,
throws her kids out the building and then a commit suicide for madness,
all that shit.
But I mean they really wrote that in paper.
They made shit up.
Some people were terrified of weed and they should be,
they should be wanting to scare everybody.
Took them 10 years of scaring people into making it illegal.
Not only that,
this is after the fucking great depression,
so people were cautious as it is,
you know?
I mean that was a crazy time.
Easy to brainwash people.
Back then everyone was getting the radio.
There's one radio station,
they go to the movies to watch a Newsreel,
total propaganda,
newsreels.
You never got the truth.
I feel like it's never any truth in that.
I feel like he's just starting to get a good rap right.
Just now starting to come down to the dock.
That's how long cause as a kid,
I remember as a kid,
even in high school,
I mean if you're smoking weed,
you're an idiot.
That's how I felt.
I felt that way until I met Eddie.
I felt that way until I was 28 I felt that way.
About six months ago I started hanging out with you guys.
I gotta be honest.
Pretty cool.
Well anybody that tells you that people on weed or lazy,
it's like you.
I don't,
you got to pay attention to all the shit I'm doing.
There's no way I'm lazy.
I just,
I'm not.
I'm a lot of things lazy.
He's not one of them.
Duke,
it might've gotten more intense with weed.
People who are lazy are lazy and people when you're,
the one thing about the,
the marijuana is the paranoia that it gives you about if you're doing the wrong
shit.
These guys wanting to war,
I fight really good.
Fight a fight.
I think that paranoia makes you work harder.
You try to keep that paranoia at bay.
It's like a wolf.
You want to do everything you can to fight off whatever the fuck that thing's
warning you against.
Cover your bases.
That's why it's so easy to get high and go on stage cause he's done comedy a
million fucking times.
It's easy.
Yeah.
It's not something you're scared of doing.
Something you own is high.
When you're on stage 99.9% of the time,
that'd be a yes.
No,
I do like I did a couple sober sets this week.
This is fine.
I like doing set,
so I did the ice house of the night's over.
It's fine,
but you prefer to be like being high when I'm coming up with shit,
that's when I especially like being high because I don't know what I'm going to
say.
It's just comes creative.
You get into that flow state where you're not there anymore,
you're not there anymore and things just come out of nowhere and sometimes they
come out of nowhere and right after it comes out of your mouth,
you're fucking laughing hysterically like that and you can't even,
it gets,
it's not really your own shit.
It's the weeds joke we'd gave you that joke.
We don't look too we.
Yeah.
And you're like laughing cause we gave you the shift stealing leads.
Shit,
we'd gave you this awesome.
Jeremy came out of your mouth.
But that's like the,
you're the channel.
Well,
let's,
where you,
humility really comes in when it comes to certain aspects of psychedelics.
It's like you,
you get,
you get the realization while you're doing it.
Like if you're saying something that's profound or whatever,
I like to pitch.
This isn't even really your thoughts,
you know,
this is like,
this is coming to you through the plant to the plant.
And Eddie,
you,
you do Jujitsu high a lot.
Always,
always.
I mean,
he'll take a workout and not be high,
but why bother?
Yeah.
So like,
it's the only reason why you would bother.
It's like there's a benefit to not being high.
You get high for a tournament.
No,
no,
no.
I won.
It's not,
uh,
we doesn't make you feel good or bad.
It just makes you feel way more of what you're feeling.
So they're going to be nervous.
If you're gonna do something that's gonna make you nervous,
I wouldn't suggest you smoking it.
Wait,
really?
Oh yeah.
It could,
it could,
it can get paranoid.
So,
uh,
but when you,
if you're going to do something that is not going to give you that you love,
like he's just going to go do Jujitsu and you're just going to have fun.
Yeah.
Then you smoke.
We didn't have more fun because that's what you're feeling and like,
yeah,
this is awesome.
You're not,
you're not,
you're not nervous or anything.
So I'm,
I'm worried if I got into weed I would just become like 320 pounds cookie
monster.
You wouldn't do that.
Why would you do that?
Cause I love to eat,
so to say.
Dude,
do you know how much I eat?
I eat so much when we go to restaurants,
people think I'm joking.
Like when I go to restaurants after shows,
I ordered two meals and they'll go,
do you still want the steak?
I go,
I want that too.
And they're like this too much food.
And like it's not too much food.
Just bring it,
you're pretty lean too though.
That's good.
Genetics,
good genetics.
But I also work out,
I work out,
man.
You gotta you gotta you gotta do it.
You've got to work out.
Well,
no I wouldn't.
I know I'm not you.
Of course you do.
But I'm saying for people that complain about it,
man,
it's just that simple.
If you like to eat,
bitch,
you better burn that shit off.
True.
But I definitely have good genetics too.
There's some people that they could look at a cake and they get fat.
Yeah.
But you do get the munchies though.
You do get the munchies and it does for me,
cause I got a sweet dude.
You work out so hard and if you've got high and got paranoid about getting fat,
you probably can try to work out even harder.
He's probably like,
but it's an extra sessions just to lean up.
You know,
you're,
you're on some crazy diet right now,
right?
You're looking slender.
You sexy pitch.
Look at his face.
It's all taught every bit to look at them.
You look,
you might be hitting me.
You're obviously giant,
but you look like Lena,
you're losing body fat if you're doing something.
Yeah.
Just been doing this diet and my trainer had me on a no carb diet for two weeks.
No carbs,
no carbs at all.
Hmm.
Eddie did that shit for years.
Really low carb.
Low carb.
Well,
you'd take the cans.
I was doing that Atkins thing.
And you stopped doing it?
Yeah.
How come?
How much protein or no,
you know,
I don't know man.
It was,
I hung in there and hung in there,
man,
you got to have a cheat day on Sunday.
You have to have under 30 carbs a day.
If you could do that under 30 carbs a day,
then on one out of the seven days,
Sunday you can eat whatever the fuck you want for just one meal or the whole
day.
The whole day you have a cheat day,
you just slept.
So I was living my life just for Sunday.
I was just trying to get the fucking Sunday.
I didn't care about Friday we went out.
I just want her to get the fuck.
I was just thinking about bread and how it's going.
And then Sunday I couldn't wait for the sun to come up.
When the sun came up.
I would just tear shit up and then I would get too full and I go,
here's my deck at the end.
Anything now I can't,
and I smelled smoke.
I smoke a lot of,
we try and get the munchies going,
well fuck the sun's going down.
I'm not even hungry.
Fuck,
I'm trying.
Then I,
I I because live in like a crazy man.
Yeah.
I was like,
now I'm starting to tell you how crazy was he used to.
We used to go to restaurants and eat and he would take the bread and he would
break the bread apart and smell it.
He wouldn't eat the bread and everybody would want bread.
They were like,
what the fuck is going on with the bread?
Eddie had taken like every piece of bread and broken apart.
So it's often,
did you get good results from it or just,
I was really lean and uh,
I'd never been that muscular or anything,
but I was losing and I was single.
It was right.
And you know,
I was a single as hell and the leaner I got the uh,
uh,
easier meeting members of the opposite,
the opposite sex where,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
definitely right away everything changed.
Exactly.
I was starving my brain.
But then that Sunday,
that Sunday eventually turned into,
I'm going to start Saturday night now let's see what have I tested?
It would,
my body is still change cause you know,
if you've got 30 grams a day,
Monday through Saturday,
somehow your body is fixed in a way that you could trash on Sunday and
it,
and it doesn't make any difference with your weight.
It'll reject everything and now you live on,
so now I'm on Saturday night,
late Saturday night I'd say,
fuck it,
I'm going to stop.
And I'd go six months and I go,
that was my thing.
It hasn't,
my weight hasn't changed.
Fuck you could actually take it into that night before.
So Saturday nights I couldn't wait Saturday during the day,
I'm like,
fucking when,
when do I start this?
Like when the sun goes down,
I would just get too crazy.
And then it turned into Saturday morning I would start and then it was okay,
Saturday and Sunday I'm going to have a cheat day,
a pancake,
and then it turned into Friday night and then I just forget.
And then it was just crazy and I just stopped.
My focus was known book in the win column.
I wonder how much longer frank Mir can keep going if he loses this fight.
We're going to have to bring them on fucker in here for,
I think you'd be a surprise dog.
No,
I'm gonna bring him in here.
Right?
John's got something.
You could bring them in and said,
Joe,
you do the same.
And I have to be there saying nothing.
You're going to be the guy that they talked to afterwards and console and you
know they're gonna.
I'll just be patching bro.
You hanging in there Joe?
Crucifies doing,
Bro.
I've been there man.
Don't worry.
[inaudible]
support group.
And then once a week you have the support group podcast turned out,
turned twice it twice.
If we could bring Tex Cobb in this room right now and have a conversation with
us all,
I'd go,
okay,
cool.
Yeah,
it's like scared straight.
You're going to start bringing in like a,
don't forget you're still alive.
He died right now,
but dude,
bring in Tony Norris.
Listen to it.
Listen to Tex Cobb these days.
Really?
Oh,
good Lord.
That's aw man.
He had an acting career for a while.
Bill.
Really uncommon.
Valerie was down common values.
Good man.
I was really,
he was a kickboxer before.
He was a boxer too.
You know,
he was a accomplished kickboxer and it's over.
I don't know who this guy is.
Larry Holmes.
Tex Cobb.
He got beat up by Larry Holmes.
So bad.
Howard Cosell quit calling boxing.
Wow.
Yup,
I'm done.
He said,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm done.
And I disgusted.
Yeah,
he wa he wouldn't remember watching.
My mother was with me and my mother was saying,
my mother said,
she literally said I should get,
my father was saying this is a slaughter and they stopped the fight.
My mother said he may have,
he may have an extra plate and is far ahead so he's probably fine.
I remember mother said that an extra
physiology physiology,
he may have another plate and as far ahead to he's five and my husband was a guy
I knew he didn't did a coat in the winter,
he never wore coat and she goes,
oh he probably hasn't had an enlarged heart.
So it pumps lots of blood to his,
you have a sore throat,
a scarf on like sort of in homage to the east coast.
Yes.
Yes I do.
I
find that I've been watching Downton Abbey
probably.
Gosh shouting yesterday.
We're shouting full.
I'm passionate.
No,
I'm just super passionate about the town fire.
He don't give a fuck.
He came in here and he'd say,
you know what,
I'm going to go in there and I'm not going to give a fuck and took it off cause
I'm hard cause you got a non parenthood of being hot.
And I'm like my neck suddenly felt the fiery Alcantara.
He's a bad motherfucker.
I don't know a Frankie signs because you don't know fighting bro.
Frankie,
same.
How'd he say his name?
Sans?
What's his background?
Turn this up Joe.
We have a timeshare in Tom.
Frankie's like,
yeah,
I love some toilet paper is a six pack in the fridge.
Only speaks to Uri.
All Co content kind of power.
How do we,
however you want to say it.
He's a bad motherfucker dude.
He's really good.
That's that guy that you know.
That was one of the most impressive victories for Uriah Faber when he beat this
dude because Uriah came at him guns blazing like within the first couple of
seconds and then like literally 15 seconds into the fight,
he's mounted the guys on top of your Ryan and he's holding them there for the
whole round.
I mean,
he's hitting them.
There's a lot of ground and pound going on,
but you're right towards the end of the round gets out of the position and then
it just coming after him for the end of that second round,
third round puts the pace,
just puts the base on them and you could see the dude going,
Jesus Christ,
when is this motherfucker get tired?
Chill man is one of the most impressive performances of your rise career.
Like a lot of people don't even talk about that fight and it's because they
started off so bad.
I think Alcantara had his back.
I know he mounted him and,
but he,
he,
he got him in a very compromising position very early in the fight when
everybody's dry and everybody's at full strength.
Trump got out of it and gave it your all men and I'll beat the brakes off of it.
One of the coolest things ever,
I heard a fight or say came from your eye favors mouth.
He,
someone's beat him.
It was a close decision.
One of those epic battles.
I don't know,
I forget who it was.
He's only lost title fights by decision.
Right.
And he,
he said after one of those fights,
because I don't feel that bad.
I mean,
I was a close fight.
Could have gone either way.
I'm right there in the mix.
I'm in the top.
I'm mixing it up.
Even though I lost,
I'm like right there.
He said,
I think I'm a smidgen off.
Yeah.
So that's like,
he has such a great attitude.
He's always one one loss away or one went away from title shot always.
Well he's going to go to 45 now,
which is very interesting.
Frankie.
Right.
That's a crazy fight,
man.
Him and Frankie hunger 45 because he wants to fight Frankie.
He doesn't want to fight Tj.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I think he feels that,
you know,
it's not necessarily fight his teammate
and uh,
I think he probably would like to take a break off that fucking horrible weight
cut to get done in one 40 get smart.
It's not a bad idea at all.
In a super fight with Frankie is fuck way better for him than Tj.
Yeah.
And if he does lose,
hey,
it's not even as division apparently.
I know,
apparently he's a,
an amazing businessman.
Owns a lot of properties.
Yeah.
It's [inaudible] it,
yeah.
He's a beast when it comes to business.
And we talked about that before,
but yeah,
I apologize.
Yeah,
no,
he's an ambitious dude,
man.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
He's the most,
for sure the most famous and the most popular guy that has not won a UFC title
has been in the mix for as long as he's been in the mix.
When he was a WEC champion,
was it like 2006 there's a while ago.
Yeah.
I remember he broke both his hands against Mike Brown.
Throwing elbows.
And I,
and I actually talked to him,
I said,
do you practice that?
He goes,
no man,
no I didn't.
I've just like started throwing my elbows cause I was like,
there's nothing else I could do at that point.
I was like crazy when an is after,
you know,
the first fight where Mike Brown caught him.
He got too aggressive.
My Brown Mike Brown caught him on the chin.
He used to be known for his insane ground and pound where he would do something
that no one has ever done.
I've never seen anybody,
but I guess it's cause he's light.
He would get in someone's guard.
You takes,
take them all down in the beginning of his career,
getting the guard and then he would like raise up and lift them up,
slammed them down.
And at the same time ricochet and to elbows.
Nobody else has ever done that.
He would be in the guard.
Holian pick them up,
slam them,
and then boom,
land elbows.
He's got like a crazy little move.
Know what I'm talking about?
Yeah,
I know.
Smart Dude Man.
And then he decided,
you know what,
I'm just going to stand up with fools.
And then he just,
he liked standing up explosive man.
He like,
he started getting really good at finishing too.
That's when you know you're I favor was a wrestler.
He did,
uh,
Abu Dhabi,
2005,
he went against bowel and being a black belt.
He was a blue belt at the time,
but he was at an amazing wrestler.
Stalemated Ballymena stalemate can beat him cause he was on top.
He just bounced me and I couldn't get on top of MS is raising two boys.
I saw,
I won't say who he was,
who he was wrestling with,
but uh,
I watched Henner Gracie.
I'd never seen Jujitsu on that level where I was white clothes.
I just had,
I really honestly had never seen that where he took high level,
high level monster dudes and was tapping them at will.
Mixed martial arts guys.
Yes.
Who Henna.
Henna Gracie.
We're at,
uh,
at the Gracie Academy.
I've actually never seen that kind of effortless excellence,
uh,
with,
with guys who were just huge and strong.
Yeah.
Henry are very,
very good.
That's very good.
I love raised from the time you're a baby.
Your Dad,
how could they not talk to them?
That's what they've been doing it since they were in.
And I talked to him about that and I said,
you know,
you seem to be
like you're chunking information.
So what happens is as soon as they do something,
you've already been there.
You know exactly what's going on in your way ahead of me.
He goes,
that's exactly right.
So his body position is already,
he's already ahead of you.
Tell us a steady bravo.
I was actually going,
that's why I was bringing it up.
I was like,
that's how it must feel right.
Anyway,
we really good.
He's getting his heart back.
She can do some quick claim to,
so last girl doing the raise the roof.
Yeah,
let's just to kiss.
Kiss and then she draws you in.
Backhand kiss.
Oh,
that's the new shit that might be on Instagram.
All the bitches going to be doing Mario Yamasaki is going to be pissed because
he's not even on mine.
Why does he do that?
A hard thing.
Is that to me or write to us?
There's a rumor.
It's to me it was a rumor going on.
Hey Mario,
we did have a talk with the ring card.
Girls come to me.
Something cool a sir.
Try not to shave the middle of your head like that.
Alcantara I was back.
Very little flexibility trying to work that rubber guard and it's like a rubber
guard can't get it.
Look as though was so stiff.
He is and he's that drive you crazy when you see guys like that when they're in
this position where men,
if that dude at some flexibility,
he had had full control of that spot.
It doesn't piss me off ever.
Come on son.
I mean I'm not pissed.
I don't mean piss but as [inaudible] does it like like puzzle you that a gun
just stretching and there's just too much to train man that they would,
if it worked for sure and they saw it and they didn't have to search for it and
do the research and it was just in their face that it worked and everyone's
doing it,
they would do it.
But until then stick to what we already know.
Let's just keep going.
Got To work on his striking and get to get your cardio together.
Fuck new.
We don't have time for new shit.
That's,
that's what they're feeling.
I understand.
It's weird.
He'd even go forward if it's not your shit.
Like if you're not that flexible at it,
he just found himself.
Yeah,
he just found himself in a spot off his back.
That's right.
When you're down there and panic and especially in the first round that's your
go to.
It's kind of weird.
You got a good point.
Anybody can acquire the flexibility required it.
Anybody can get into Lotus,
but you have to put a lot of time into it and most people aren't willing to put
in the time.
Where the fuck is John Wayne par?
See if he's texting me.
I might be a little late.
Oh my driving from San Diego.
Hope that's okay.
No problem.
You're world champion brother.
Whatever you say.
He's a good dude too.
John Wayne parts a good dude.
I don't know why I love those front kick so much cause they were just so damned.
We just joke about them.
Yeah,
we made that video and my garage where you were asking me about.
I'm like dad,
it's the odds.
You landed it right on the chin.
Not so good now.
It killed it.
I never,
I don't think in my entire fight and career ever kicked someone in the face with
a front kick
and now everyone's stoner.
Man,
he just waiting for the chin for the chance to ever get there on him.
I never write down the Middle Anderson when he landed that fucking front kick
on,
Victoria changed the whole world crazy.
Everybody was like,
oh,
of
course I was speech.
I'll Steven Seagal.
I got,
I was speechless when I saw that so that when Liotta landed the jumping front
kick karate,
they could style crane,
not fucking Randy coture.
Up until then,
it wasn't part of your training sessions.
If you weren't MMA fighter and you didn't stick that in there,
you're like,
why are you practicing that shit?
It's a waste of your time.
You know what?
Nobody would,
nobody was practicing it,
you know?
Now they are.
Do you know what opened it up a lot in MMA as opposed to in kickboxing is the,
the takedowns and the worry about the sprawl and a lowered stance.
There's a,
there's a different approach because guys are always worried about both things.
You worried about possible takedowns so you're training in a different way.
You're not throwing a lot of the same techniques.
So you're catching a guy that's like,
might be leaning forward a little bit more,
might be of a lower bay,
might not be able to move back and forth out of the way is easy because you're
not seeing it that much in kickboxing.
You're seeing like a front push kicks to the face a little bit and some of the
kickboxing bouts and tie bouts,
you're seeing some of that and they really don't land right.
They kind of just,
they just kind of push back because they're,
they have a different stance.
They'll lean way back,
they'll lean back light on their feet.
It's a different,
it's a different style.
The MMA fighters,
a lot of them are,
uh,
they're,
they're positioning them.
So like Vitara squares off more because Vituro is always worried about the
takedowns.
And he actually used to teach that at Carlson Gracie's whose taste the different
stance.
Like,
he was like,
you know a lot of these guys,
he was actually talking about Maury Smith at the time who was a,
I think he was the UFC heavyweight champion.
Beautiful.
Take tea.
I think it would be Mark Coleman.
Yeah,
right there on his back.
Willy slip off,
look at the grease slips right off.
He's way off.
That's all grease.
What kind of lost it.
Yeah.
But anyway,
Vitto was explaining how Maury still stands like a kickboxer and that he had a
square off more and he's like,
you have to learn how to throw all your punches from almost like a horse dance.
I mean a square stance,
much less sideways.
And if you look at a guy like Floyd Mayweather,
I mean he's coming at you like Tony Sideways,
completely sideways and it makes a small target like that,
but get your leg and your leg kicked out or that's true.
But you could also get taken down and put the ties.
Understand where,
so it's more available and MMA because of the way people stand.
Yeah,
definitely.
Kickboxing there too.
Sideways,
too sideways and they move back to easy.
They're moving like too upright.
They moved like watch like someone like a like like a real high level Thai guy
like watch like you know one of those dudes from like from Gloria what?
Blue cow,
bull cow.
Poor promac that guy watch that guy wouldn't.
When people throw kicks at him and it's fucking moves back like a snake,
like the kicks coming towards me,
leanings way back like a snake and then comes back to your fucking legs out
money to take you down.
Then it becomes even more effective.
Now he's coming in Boone
so you're going to catch him.
He's going to be open for it.
If you throw in like if you're,
you're leaning back like the way a lot of those guys will do and moving back and
forth,
but it's like guys all time that figuring out when to take you down.
You know,
especially if you're committing forward guys,
but when you don't have to worry about strike or you don't have to worry about
takedowns you change your state,
you change your stance and it changes what's available.
Plus with Victor.
He,
he was more like a wide stance because vittores a power guy.
He's trying to knock dudes out second,
shut up.
He's trying to knock a dude out.
You know what's interesting about the tour man,
he doesn't have big hands at all.
It doesn't have been a small fee.
It's got like an I eight size eight.
They're not this,
they're not big and uh,
it's,
it's amazing how much power he's able to generate.
Like if you watch his fight with like Scott for Roseau back in the day when he
was 19 school,
I mean he is throwing punches that you have never seen in his or did he find his
own Gonzaga and fight?
No,
he didn't fight either one of those guys.
He fought back in the day trade talisman men.
That was his first fight in the UFC and then right after that he foot's got
frozen.
He won the tournament.
He calls it like a heavyweight title,
but it's not really everyone.
There was a guy he just machine and got with the high level kick back.
Vandelay Silva he just charged across.
Yeah,
he hit him with a powder left hand.
Yes.
He was just so much faster than,
oh,
that was a big head kick by.
I'll um,
he's like,
he's,
he's his hand speed is so goddamn blazing fast that if he catches you with one,
we'd just,
we'll,
we'll it to you with 40 more behind it before you can react.
That's what he did to van Italy.
He literally ran out.
I'm like chain punched style right across the,
the October.
I wonder what v Tor does.
If he loses loses to Whiteman,
where,
where does he go from the,
it's going to be hard for him to go off TRT after you know how many years of
being on it.
Like hardcore cause he was,
you know,
his numbers were high so he's,
he's,
he's getting off of what,
as a really high toes,
high desk.
Look at that.
Oh Shit.
Nice needs the buy.
Love those.
Can you need inside the rectal area?
It's very good question.
It's like the cop,
they're not going to stop you right in the home.
I can stop you.
I'm going to stop.
You going to,
excuse me sir.
Guy Squeeze to the rectum.
No worries.
You can need like the ass cheeks for sure.
For sure.
Hurt when you cough.
You can get all up in that as well.
What the fuck were we,
you were saying that Vitara versus why,
but you know it's,
it's,
I just,
I don't know how he's going to be able to do,
you don't,
that's the reality of getting old man.
If you're not on some sort of hormonal replacement in Europe,
(373) 083-0940 four it starts getting up there and your entire career you've
been using some sort of hormonal assistance.
I mean it's not like you're not even talking about a guy who's been entirely
natural and talking about a guy who,
oh,
this dude is taken a big tar is getting blasting this,
getting
the healthy rubber neck like his own
little separate that the old blossom,
just get that little slippery here.
Double outside ashy slip,
right.
What is called double outside?
Ashy.
What does that the leg position.
Oh son,
who,
who invented it?
I said Japanese.
It's a position that existed as long as catch wrestling and all that shit
existed.
It's nothing new.
Why did I just learned?
I just learned the proper name.
Why is it ashy?
I don't know,
man.
That's a good question.
Is it a judo thing or is it a,
what's the origin?
I don't know.
Cause all those Hari Goshi and decided I'm going to learn those names one of
these days and be a beast.
I'll tell you what I'm more excited for than even Pacquiao Mayweather is.
I've been talking Shit to count about his taekwondo days for years now.
His wife has proof,
I guess of what?
Oh,
look at.
Look at the past.
We had our pictures of me.
Ah,
she has pictures of him probably flying through the air.
Killing a cow.
That's nothing to be proud of.
Probably failing is tiny with one hand.
Sure.
It sure isn't by the way.
I just,
I been calling him a liar for years now and then is my bad.
It's like everything really.
Taekwondo though.
What did you,
did you really get a black belt?
I was a master.
Come on,
come on.
I don't know what his rank master.
What does that mean?
Let me back.
I went back to like how long did you train?
Probably seven years straight.
Seven years straight.
And where were you living with your colleagues?
Is College all through college?
You must have been training when I met you then and then three years after it
probably just just stop.
But I wasn't,
I wasn't sparring then.
I'd probably stop just then.
So when do you get your black belt?
A 1987 so how many years are we training before you got your buck up?
Two and a half.
That sounds ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's pretty fast.
Huh?
That doesn't even sound logical.
You're the Bj Penn at Taekwondo,
Huh?
Now Tech,
you get your back up pretty quick.
I don't know where you are.
Right?
But a lot faster.
You get a 14 year olds.
But that's kind of the idea is that
when you get your black belt,
then you're a student.
You know?
Now you're ready to learn.
I actually got mine in two years.
Really?
I knew you were masking it with me.
Yeah,
you can do it.
Especially when you're 15 when I was 15 I got my,
before I was 17 I had mine.
I'm seeing you pay for it in advance to pay for the black belt course.
Three years you pay for it,
you're good at some places.
That sounds like some bullshit and then there was point fighting fighting and
versus like,
you know actually hitting each other.
But you know what man,
it's like a lot of you,
what you pick up when you're young as far as like your bill.
Oh dude,
left counter,
left Tan.
A lot of like,
you know your ability to learn and shit.
It's like so much better when your body is still growing.
You know you like your,
your body's like growing,
throwing kicks.
It's like so easy.
You could take a 14 year old,
you teach them a little bit of taekwondo in two years.
They look like a wizard that's throwing,
jumping wheel kicks.
Take a 40 year old and teach them.
Tiguan died two years.
He looks like a 40 year old that just learn taekwondo differ.
He gets stuff for,
actually I did taekwondo for a year.
I thought it was going to be like bloodsport,
I want to be.
I did.
I wanted to be John Claude van Damme,
so my dad took me,
my brother Taekwondo,
and they had me punching like this,
you know,
black like this.
I said,
I'm the fuck,
fuck this noise and left after a year
after year.
That's what we started with and then my dad forced me to go for probably the
next eight months.
It's these schools,
man,
it's like there's a lot of them that are just maximizing their in their income,
but just trying to get as many students as they can and they're not teaching the
style that was a taekwondo originally was,
which most people will quit.
They'll quit because he got hard.
Yeah.
It's too hard.
You get kicked.
Getting kicked.
Sucks.
Most,
yeah.
Most of what you're doing is getting kicked.
Dudes went to sleep in my school all the time.
You always nervous every time you thought accidentally people would knock people
out accidentally on purpose too,
but accidentally friends would knock friends out.
I've seen it happen many times.
When I pass the test for my first green stripe on my white belt in karate.
The remark on the test,
I passed the test and they said that a fantastic overhand knife strike like that
was my shit and that my story and I'm thinking,
fuck,
I'm telling my friends that I got to fucking
actually thought someone fucked with me.
I got to go to my go to first.
I'm going to go.
Did you use it in the sparring?
Did use it in spar?
Spar?
It was karate.
She say nothing at all.
No sparring.
I'm going to make an assumption here.
I would assume because you guys are in taekwondo,
you guys weren't,
don't take the wrong way,
but you guys weren't good at other sports.
How does,
that's adorable.
How's it good?
Is that true?
No,
it was good at everything.
I did really good football,
basketball,
baseball,
baseball.
I played baseball as good at baseball.
The reason why I got into taekwondo is cause I was at Fenway Park to see a
baseball game.
What else?
Leaving and yeah,
I was obsessed with baseball.
I loved it.
Played all the time when I was a kid,
little league and all that shit.
And then when I was leaving,
uh,
I was,
I could hit a ball fucking far dude.
When I was a kid I had like good,
like home run power as a little,
is that right
with his hips?
Like it all,
it's translated into kicking and punching.
But I,
you know,
like I was obsessed with hitting home runs.
I struck out or I hit home runs,
Babe Ruth,
a single fucking coach ever got into my head.
They're all like,
look,
I need to get on first base.
I go,
okay,
okay.
Okay.
Pitch comes swinging for the fucking moon every time.
I didn't care if I struck out and cause I was a terrible team player.
Yeah.
I didn't give a fuck if we lost,
I'm hitting a home run.
That one is home right now.
My coach,
they would pull me aside.
He goes,
look man,
you got seven home runs at 89 strike out.
That's what I,
I either,
I either knocked that fucking hilarious,
but when I hit it,
dude,
people would go,
Holy Shit,
I got addicted to that feeling of people going,
Holy Shit.
So he played baseball it til when?
A 15.
Because when I was,
when I was realizing that I could hit the ball harder than most people my size,
it became my thing.
I get so excited about it.
So it a practice obsessive Lee and then coming home from a baseball game,
we went to see the red sox at Fenway Park.
There was the line for the teeth because it was a summertime.
There's always people walk in,
everybody took the t and it was a long line.
You'd have to wait like 45 minutes to get on the fucking train.
Just piles of people.
All these drunks piling out of Fenway Park Cause Fenway Park is right down the
street from the a the t stop.
So we were walking home and we'd pass by the j Hunt Kim Taekwondo Institute.
So,
uh,
I was already taking karate.
I was taking karate at a Joe Esposito's in Newton,
Massachusetts.
But it's hard to get there.
There was,
it wasn't good public transportation there.
I,
I get to the top of the stairs as we're walking up,
I'm hearing
like these change,
Chink,
like cause the bag's going in the air and then the chain is like stopping it
from swinging lump and I go up and as just total synchronicity,
the time I show up at the school was the time that John Lee,
who was at the time,
the most devastating student that Mr. Kim hat as far as like knockout power,
he was this really tall black dude from a really bad neighborhood.
He was like a street guy who learn martial arts learning to fight.
He had a spinning back kick that was unhealthy.
God.
This Day people say,
my,
my spinning backaches really good.
I'm telling you,
if you saw this motherfucker kicked the bag,
you would go,
oh,
that's where I got it from.
I got it from my first impressions.
Well he taught me to,
he taught me a lot of shit.
John taught me a lot of shit.
I,
we,
I went to a lot of tournaments with them actually when I was young,
when I was older,
but I walked up when he was prepared was the national champion at the time and
he was preparing for the World Cup.
So as I walked up the stairs it was like him and his final preparations for the
World Cup and it was just boom,
just fucking this bag up.
This hundred pound bag was flying through the air and bending in half.
And I remember thinking,
I never saw anybody do anything.
That's crazy.
I've never seen anybody do anything like this before.
And it was all about bag work cause Mr. Kim was like adamant about bag work and
he's like everybody throws kicks in the area that you've got to build
resistance,
you have to hit things heavy things.
He had a 200 pound bag know a series of hundred pound bags and it's 200 pound
bag that was like as big around as Joey Diaz and it was like seven feet telling
you to kick the shit out of this fucking thing.
And that was his thing man.
It's just building power.
So I became
obsessed.
So you saw that and said,
Fuck Bay,
quit risks,
wrestling,
quit baseball,
quit everything.
I was doing a bunch of sports,
but how dare you think I wasn't good at sports?
No,
it's not that I,
it was more like in my neighborhood,
if he did taekwondo,
you weren't good at anything else because it was a,
you know what I'm saying?
Cause you,
it's not a team sport.
You're not going to get picked on.
So it's like,
all right,
well what can he do?
Let's put this little bastard in Taekwondo Denver.
Denver's like taekwondo.
Not exactly heartland.
It all depends.
Every martial art depends on what school you go to.
You can go to a dog shit Jujitsu school and it's,
you know,
it's better than nothing,
but you're going to learn some shitty technique a lot of the times.
Yeah.
And that's the same with karate.
And that's the same way we talk.
Well,
no,
I just got stupid lucky man.
I was in the right place at the right time.
I mean,
you can't get a better time.
This guy was kicking up the fucking shit out of this bag and I just stood.
The way the,
the gym is set up,
you'd get to the top of the stairs is an area where you'd take her shoes off and
that area was right where the heavy bags where it was by design because Mr. Kim
wanted people to walk up the stairs and see someone murdering the bag and sign
up.
The desk is right there.
So that's where John was working out.
And like you'd go,
first of all,
you see a guy who's a black poly like boy,
he's a fucking black.
Yeah,
yeah.
But you see a black was actually doing real black belt shit that you expect a
black belt to do that.
So that was how I got hooked with one because if I came up there and it's some
fucking kid's class and they're like,
yeah,
that was my experience.
I would have been later.
I would have been so close and make a lot of money.
Teach just forms and 0.5 because you know you can,
you can have a lot of money.
You can get your black button right away.
But,
but when,
when we were hitting each other,
those gyms have a hard time.
John didn't remember any of his forms.
That's one of the things that I've learned.
Like John Leaks,
he's from Chelsea.
It was a terrible neighborhood.
It didn't know any forms.
It was man.
I remember new thing just until I can forget them.
You remember that Shit.
He would laugh about it.
It was like total street guy.
Like he's a good dude man.
He had a lot of you played sports.
I played sports on my street.
Yeah.
I played football all the goddamn time on the streets with other Mexican people,
my size and the older and stuff.
But then once,
and I,
and I played little league or junior all American football.
So when I was nine I played middle linebacker and defense event.
Dope.
Actually thought I was going to grow up to be a football player and play,
maybe Middle Linebacker,
maybe quarterback,
maybe defensive and like I was so delusional as a kid,
junior,
all American football does that.
It makes you think like it took off.
I tried to play football my freshman year.
I get into pads,
I'm in New England,
it's so cold and I just,
I want to be a football player.
I literally was a hundred and what?
Literally 110 pounds and my father was so huge,
I thought I was going to grow up to
be like him.
So it's just a question of,
you know,
growing into that and I,
I was,
I was getting hit and it was so cold in my head.
I was running away from the place and then a guy carry lane came to me and he
said,
you have to rustle.
You're just wrestle people your size.
What are you do on our foot?
Change in my life was our football coach was the assistant wrestling coach and
this mother fucker would always try to recruit people.
Yeah.
He's like,
Grogan,
you're a tough bastard.
He should be out there.
You should be out there on the fucking field.
But we had a guy in our football or in our wrestling team that was our
heavyweight.
Yeah,
he was 300 pounds.
Bobby Baker.
He was 300 pounds in high school.
And I'm not joking.
It wasn't lean.
Okay.
But he was a giant.
He was a giant dude.
I go and I just stood right next to him.
I go,
he plays football.
look,
I play wrestle one 34 right?
He's 300 pounds.
Awesome.
Fuck you.
I'm not there.
No one.
No one's breaking me.
I'm not having someone run over me and smashed me.
No thanks.
Oh,
there's going to be giving a talk.
We Love Reus Tom.
There's nothing will copy it off.
That's another different kind of white dude.
Yeah.
He,
Israel Martinez is that guy that Donald Serone head kicked.
Oh,
that's right.
This was his last fight,
right?
I believe so.
I don't know if Martine's is fought on one of the undercards I wasn't aware of.
There's so many fights going on as we were talking about.
If you're,
you know,
fight pass,
between the,
the prelims on Fox sports one and all that.
He's responsible for two of the most stomach churning submissions in the history
of the UFC.
Why?
What's the other one?
Tim Silvia snapped this fucking forearm.
Half Demon.
No it right.
He wanted to keep going and then on people that knew something was wrong.
Yeah,
he did that crazy Americana from the guard kind of thing.
That was awesome.
Frank Mir is one of the reasons I started fighting.
No one's ever done that again.
Have you ever pulled that off?
That Americana from full guard?
No.
No guys did it after that.
They were fucking around with it.
I remember guys,
we're fucking around with it in class like right after that fight.
I mean from full good.
It'd be tough to a very complex setup.
He paid someone who did more good when it sold it off.
You know,
you don't think a wrist locks work.
You think wrist locks or Ooh,
acute old Dell.
But Fred [inaudible],
he put lock or a wrist locks you from full guard.
He showed me,
man,
fuck,
this is real shit.
Wrist locks sound like something doesn't make fun of and no one really tells him
though.
There are certain girls,
they get obsessed with them and they pull them off guard and they were really
good.
You got to watch your rails and they'll use them to set up other things because
you have to spread it on your wrist and you know he'd pull it back to this set
up.
Others Cellos,
man submitted Cameron Earl with a wrist lock.
One of the trips we went to,
what was it like a wrist lock from an Omoplata?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Do you know what I mean?
You got
have you enrolled with that?
I sound like I say it's online.
Bitch.
Google it.
It is,
Eh.
He'd beat my ass.
You can watch it on youtube.
He's that good.
He's just that I can got a,
there's a wizard a wizard.
Huh?
There's a lot of high level guys now man.
I was so impressed watching Gary Tone and Havi so I'm so impressed with the
hobby.
Hobbies.
Defense is incredible.
How relaxed he is.
And that guy's mounting him and going after leg locks,
but he's bigger than Havi.
Right by quite a bit.
They were saying we're announcing the weigh ins.
They were saying one 45 and one 70 I don't know if that's accurate though.
I would say hobby would hobby was not one 45 I would say it was one 65 one 70
somebody must've just erroneously stated that.
I would say since I wasn't a weight limit and and Gary Tone and cuts down to 70
for some fights,
I would say he might've been,
he could have been one 75 one 80 maybe.
I don't know.
He so he's looked big.
It looked a lot bigger than a hobby,
but God damn,
that triangle was a thing of beauty,
man.
Gary,
tons.
Fucking everybody up.
So good.
God Damn.
He's just ripping through.
Everybody's submitting everybody.
I remember when you came on the podcast,
so you talked about that match that he had with crone.
Yeah.
Oh God.
You ever seen that?
I haven't seen it.
What happened?
Fucking crooners up fucking madman.
Nightmare.
He's up.
Matt was on crone was beating him.
He was about to get beat.
He got his back.
He was all over chrome.
How long?
Never seen crawling.
It was,
it went to the last second,
the last second he was down,
dude,
he had,
it was like a a minute left.
I forget now.
It's been a while,
but there was like a minute left.
They separated,
they stood and crump and was was going to win.
There's he a cro needed to submit them.
So with them within a minute he looks over at Hixson and he says he just does it
man.
He,
he gets,
he takes him down,
gets his back and chokes him out with like a second life special.
When I was getting ready for a metamorris crone was also on the card and so I'd
go to his gym and train with them and I remember when we got done afterwards I
was looking over and he's doing these breathing techniques.
I was like,
damn,
this motherfucker's are Real Samurai white dude from Denver.
Like trying to do his shit.
You know his heart rate down and look at his dad.
You've seen the movie choke.
Where's dad works on that stuff?
Yeah,
you should learn that shit,
man.
That's an interesting thing to learn.
The breathing to breathing,
yet he does it all the time he took,
he took me through it.
It's just,
you know,
you got to do it all the time.
It's become part of your game.
You've got to master your abs somehow.
Such a beast,
man.
Crone.
He's a special special dude.
Yeah.
Imagine that.
Just the Jeanette Dicks,
his genetics.
I mean,
come on.
So you're,
you're born into the greatest Jujitsu family.
Fuck that.
The greatest martial arts family by a long shot.
Like what's the second greatest martial arts family other than the Gracies.
And how about your dad is Hixon you know,
dad's not Helson.
I'm playing the flute.
Your Dad's not Carlson.
What if you did though?
What if you were all into the flute and Dude's
Oh,
oh,
come on.
Flowers
are not all with the fact that you called it a five degree.
What if you wear a scarf and wearing to flutes and in you're a Gracie,
like Hixon scientist.
You just say,
fuck.
Just dying.
Dying to get the word flutist out all mine if it right in my throat all year.
How many times on here do you use flowers?
I had a good year.
A crazy flout filled year.
I bet he said you say it every time on your own podcast.
Yeah,
I started,
I started my own buck as everything because it's really,
unless I go,
I have to say,
I've always fantasized about being a flutist and now the Prime Kevin?
No.
If you had to be honest,
like how many times a year do you think you break out the word flutist?
Um,
it is a word that I think about a lot and I just never have time to really
working in until just now.
Cause I don't have sophisticated company.
I'm pretty sure that that's the only time I've ever said it is repeating.
You just know.
Yeah.
I don't think it'd be on flowers,
but I expect that with a guy that came in with a scarf.
Cashmere is 100% we went deer hunting.
He was wearing cashmere,
he just called himself the cashmere killer.
He's in Montana tested killer.
He killed her to really one of the most desolate spots in North America.
I mean,
it's fucking wilderness.
There's no one out there.
He's wearing cashmere can't,
you can't grow anything.
You get to the top of a mountain and you know when you looked at for deer and
you look off,
I like,
like how remote you are,
like the area you're in.
It's pretty cool.
It's really weird.
And then you look over and there's county Kashmir,
Kashmir and his cell phone.
Oh yeah
dude.
You're in the middle of nowhere.
You can't grow anything.
You're in clay to,
you walk around in clay.
It's crazy.
Cat Mud,
clay,
cactus clay and like Rye.
We'd grow there.
Well you know why it's,
it's clay.
It's literally the bottom of an ancient sea.
It's the great western inland sea.
These of dinosaurs fucking rolling around that you find like shells,
you find like,
like seashells.
They're millions of years ago.
That was an ocean.
Eddie,
you don't hunt.
You don't go with these guys hunting.
No.
Sorry,
you're saying it's too big,
right?
It should be.
Well,
you just never tried.
It goes down.
You know,
guys didn't know how to hunt.
Those are the guys you want to be though.
When you're hunting.
The hunting is the fun is actually the amount.
You laugh together like you and I laugh more when we hunt because a lot of times
it's cold and a little bit miserable.
Well and then they don't know anybody like us.
Like they didn't know.
They don't ever have comedians come hunting with them.
Other hunters truths of Joe and I had a captive audience.
They have nowhere to go.
It's great.
In all fairness,
I have a captive,
I mean you have a captive audience and me,
I bring you along cause I know he's always on.
Plus we can talk,
you know,
we could have like real conversations like especially that first day I'm like,
I didn't know where these guys are going to fucking get this key.
You know,
who knows.
This could be,
this could be a disaster.
Who knows what kind of guys were going with.
Literally I go there and I go like this.
I got to go,
oh I'm going to make Joe Laugh all fucking day.
That's my job.
All we did,
all we did was just how laughing,
shoot things.
And how are you guys laughing?
Oh my God,
we're crying.
They had a five day Brian Cowen comedy show.
By the end of it,
they knew the rhythm too.
They knew it was all gay stuff.
So anytime,
anytime they would bend over to pick up firewood.
Let me help you out here.
You got doing this right?
You're going to do this hunting shell.
Shh.
What do you,
what's,
what's the,
the hips,
the botox to get the red hair.
That could work better.
A hunting show with that character.
You could do that.
Guides.
I basically sexually harass Dan Dodi the whole time.
And it's,
and it's in these shows.
Oh yeah,
they did.
They look very little.
[inaudible] what you see on the show is like,
just the,
the,
the usable parts.
It's a hunting show and the sportsmans channel the fucking at all.
Give me some of that wine to what kind of wine you got their fellow.
Oh,
that's a nice,
it's a beautiful,
the scanner to scan it,
but it's,
um,
it's very satisfying.
Yeti.
You would enjoy.
You love meat,
man.
It'd be,
I don't love meat that much.
I don't like any game.
Me like elk and I don't like or you don't know.
I never had to say that.
You don't know at Fuddruckers and they got all that shit.
Just stop right now.
That's like saying karate doesn't work.
I saw Fred Volare but Eddie,
Eddie,
Eddie.
That's first of all,
it's farm raised where it's farm raised.
Alchemize via cow that grow those fucking things in cages in New Zealand.
They cut the meat up and they ship it over here.
You're not getting wild elk from North America because wild elk from North
America,
you can't sell.
I don't like Cam.
Try dated.
I don't like,
you don't have to camp.
You could stay on the lodges.
Stand lodges.
A lot of times you've done it hardcore,
but we've also done it where we stay in a house that's different.
We've done a hardcore twice,
like hardcore
jungle Rinella.
No,
I'm not in the jungles where you go to a gentleman and hug like leopards.
I been to prom is no,
I've been to a jungle.
You don't want to be in.
You don't want to be in the jungle.
And I've been in the gym.
I'd rather do that.
I've been in the rain forest.
You like general listening.
He got to hear this because he actually was working as a bug scientist.
I went,
I went to Indonesia and went and tracked orangutans.
Let me,
let me tell you why you never want to go in the jungle.
Ever,
ever.
Dude.
Bugs.
You'll get eaten by mosquitoes.
You'd have to carry a sulfur coil,
not just bug spray,
a sulfur coil.
You have to sit in your hammock.
Please don't lie on the ground because if you're laying the ground,
uh,
leeches,
we'll get into your skin.
And not to mention those wonderful ants and wasps.
What about you at the story you told about putting the Turpentine on the posts
of the,
the,
yeah,
you have to put per turpentine.
So every house there is raised up and you put Turpentine,
you soak the,
the wood in terms of why?
Because you don't want to be in the way of the soldier ants when they're
hunting.
If they're foraging,
they'll walk right over you.
If they're hunting,
they will come up those posts.
They will come into a hut and kill you and they'll jump on you.
They'll basically cover you and sting you in your,
the normal thinking that happens too.
They kill elephants.
What they climb in Indonesia and Africa as well.
They climb into an an elephant's ear and they'll start eating it's fucking
brain.
You can hear them coming there.
That's how many there are.
I'm from real.
You can hear a buzz.
I go,
you want to hear a crazy statistic?
Here's a crazy statistic about ants.
The body mass,
like the weight of ants on earth,
the amount of ants is exactly the same or close to it as the weight of people.
Yeah.
That's how many ants there are.
So shitload.
And now why is,
how do these Amazon Indian survive these bugs saying is that the Dayak who I was
with,
they don't sweat.
Even though you're sweating,
losing counselor,
they don't sweat.
They there.
They've adapted to their environment so they can and bugs don't.
The mosquitoes don't really bite them.
Why?
Because they over millennia,
they developed a,
they evolve to develop resistance to bugs,
to the bugs of that area.
That makes sense.
Totally makes sense.
But there's some bugs is still get them like Rinella was in Bolivia.
You know Rinella just got back from Bolivia where he ate a monkey.
Oh my shot and cooked and ate a monkey.
Not Him,
but the people in the tribe.
No,
he didn't get sick,
but it's disturbing.
Yeah.
Watching them throw this monkey on the fire.
It looks very,
very fucking human monkey like a chimpanzee or hail.
You want a little monkey with a tail.
But he got stung by a bullet ant.
He was there and he was in agony.
It's
the worst.
But these,
those guys get stung to as a part of their coming of age ritual.
They're not immune to that shit now.
They're not.
WASPS could give a shit how long you've lived in the area.
It's going to hurt just as much hobby lobby and our Martine's is an interesting
fight,
man.
His hobby lobby's coming off that loss to Benson Henderson.
It was a close fight.
Yup.
Got pulled into deep water.
He's beaten good guys.
He beat Jorge Mosbey Dolly.
Remember he hit him with that weird,
we'll kick really awkward.
We'll kick.
It's a really good grappler.
Yeah.
Real world champion Samba.
I think he was correct.
And His uh,
suplexes are off the charts.
Throw you on your head.
Yeah.
But Martine's is high level Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
Black belt could kick boxer.
He was holding his own with cowboy mean he was getting,
he was hanging in there until he got head kicks.
Cowboy was setting him up,
but he was doing well up to that moment.
He's a good fighter.
Cowboy.
She's so fast.
Those head kicks and he's not afraid to fight off his back.
So he's not scared throwing that,
you know,
he's not worried about anything.
Having a good guard.
Eddie.
Oh he said this so huge for kickboxers cowboys fighting a Colby.
That's what we're talking about there.
I haven't had a,
I got,
I wish you good guard with that motherfucker have one.
Yeah.
That's a weird fight.
That's a real weird fight.
Tough
fight.
Tough.
If there's anybody.
Yeah,
for,
well for both of them.
But if there's any time to fight Khabib,
it's now off this long way off long layoff and knee surgery.
Who knows?
Like where his knees really at.
Great.
Take down.
Right?
Nine is Bam.
He gets that and that.
Sure.
Nope,
this reus Tom on his back.
Interesting to see how big it gets.
Hard.
Look,
how's that car loan wall crawl?
Damn.
He doesn't like that.
You're allowed to grab the fence.
Getting him off the fence,
which you might as well because all they do is warn you.
Pushing him away from the fence.
That's awesome.
Right?
It's great control on that leg.
So interesting.
Coming up does not want this guy on there.
Get Him.
Get up.
Oh Man.
Not Today.
My friend day.
No
land.
That's his gig.
That's right there.
He's got good jets.
Ooh.
See all that grease seal.
They just slipped so easy.
Yeah.
His thing was the suplex and then guys get aware of it and once you get to a
certain level,
well he's kind of taken one out now that someone took him down and engaged him
in grappling.
Right?
True.
That's a high level take down.
That looked like a college wrestler.
Take that.
Great.
That's his world.
I mean that's hobby labs world and all of sudden he's on his back for the first
time.
His UFC career.
He's been trying to stand up more lately.
He did great shots.
This black.
Oh,
that's why I don't top and couldn't do any of that too.
That's a nice right hand.
He's through that.
Like that's like a semi chocolate Dell style over here and right.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean Martine's didn't really threaten him at all.
Right.
No Brazilians have great skin there.
I said it beautiful.
Yeah.
Kara mouse,
like a Mocha,
the caramel.
I'm not mad at it.
Nah,
no reason to be.
You know what I mean?
Brennan?
Yeah,
I feel,
yeah,
it's tough.
You have had of that kind of skin.
Don't sell yourself short.
So does headache.
Nah,
not really.
I said both of you listen to Yellowstone blows.
We might all be living in Brazil in five years.
Yeah.
Yellowstone explodes and half the fucking country is dead.
Is there a chance of that?
Fuck yeah.
Giant,
giant one.
Huge Jansen.
No bullshit.
So a continent killer really?
Well,
why the fuck isn't seen Antonio?
This dude,
it's,
it's Whoa.
Nice kicked right by Martine's.
It's a,
what they call a Caldera volcano,
which is a volcano that's so violent that it starts out as like a mountain.
The mountain explodes and what you're left with is a crater that they have to
look at it from satellites to even recognize what it is.
They didn't even know it was a volcano until Mike,
the two thousands like when when they started looking at the area with a
satellite imagery,
they started going,
wait,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck are we looking at here?
And then they went,
Oh gee,
oh no.
I realize it's 600 kilometers wide.
That's why there's nothing we can do.
Oh,
not only these isn't nothing that goes off every six eight Yellowstone
goes off every six to 800,000 years.
When's the last time went off?
600,000 so we got 200,000 we're good.
If we're lucky,
it could go off tomorrow.
I mean,
they've had thousands of earthquakes every year for a long time.
They have thousands of earthquakes every year.
I'll give you go to Yellowstone.
Hmm?
Almost every day you're going to have a fucking earthquake.
Sometimes multiple.
Hey,
he's here.
John Wayne part.
Ladies and gentlemen,
have a seat.
We're on the,
on the air right now.
What's up brother?
You're Alpha brain gym.
There's some over man.
How you doing buddy?
You scare me with that talk Joe.
You gotta be honest,
my man.
That's why I don't smoke weed.
Cause if I did I'd be running for the hills right now.
Packing Shit,
beef.
Afraid of,
but there's nothing anybody can do about it.
You'd have to just get to another spot.
You know there's hills.
My only option.
Well,
Australia would be a good option.
I'm not mad at John Wayne par.
Let you fucking know.
Okay,
that's,
we might catch John.
We might have to move to Australia.
If the Yellowstone blows.
Can we crash at your place?
Just so friendly.
Well,
there's the plan.
Plan B gentlemen.
Um,
this dude is a,
your friend.
Oh Hey Andy.
What's up man?
We got to get,
get him a chair or something.
Jamie,
we've got a chair for him.
So I'm sit down.
Well,
we're watching Bruce Dom,
hobby lav and a Adriana Martine's first round.
Very good round for Martine's.
Latinas won that round.
John Wayne par multiple time Moy Thai world champion in the motherfucking house.
Ah,
this is amazing to be here.
Good to have you brother.
Flying over from another part of the world.
We're talking about places to escape.
When Yellowstone,
the super volcano explodes and kills everybody in North America.
So,
uh,
Australia is a strong possibility.
I feel like you just broke news on that.
No,
everybody knows.
You guys all knew.
You knew this.
You knew only through Joe,
only through Joe,
but it's one of the things that,
you know,
if it does blow,
don't worry,
you're dying and it's fine.
Well,
you might die slow if you're anywhere like outside of the perimeter of them die
or it's not that bad.
The for everything a hundred miles around it is dead instantly.
What about,
well,
Yellowstone here,
it went fully live on the beach.
You're going to be
people jumping in the ocean,
so you're dying by lava.
Don't worry.
It's just I live in stone.
Yeah,
but it's the,
uh,
the heat and the Google plus is one the gun and go right there at the,
you're the last one and you can get on your boogie board.
And
what would probably happen is that the son would get completely blotted out.
That's what,
that's what's up.
No more vegetables.
No more vicious animals would die.
Rotten meat everywhere.
Candy or food.
You fought diseases.
Say this,
you guys are fucked in Calabasas.
Wow.
Everybody's fucked.
Everybody beach through their fucked your Fox.
First of all,
guess what?
Fuck
face.
The beach ain't even going to be there because you had a super volcano.
You're dealing with massive earthquakes.
Tsunamis without a doubt.
Know
you'll catch a wave all the way to Japan except Jesus Christ.
Remember escape from La.
Yes,
Russell.
Dude,
he was on a wave,
so ridiculous.
It was like I'm green screen and he's serving on green screen,
so we're just all screwed.
What you're saying,
just exalt Jesus Christ as your savior and you'll be fine.
It's one of those things where when it does blow,
it's going to kill him.
A major chunk of the population of the world,
not just the United States,
but of the world.
There's a one that happened in Indonesia that 70,000 years ago and they think
it's one of the main reasons why there's like when you teach trace the genetic
lineage.
Dan,
it was a good fucking fight at his hobby lobby.
Just cracked him with a left hook.
I can take a shot,
man.
Yeah.
Um,
they think there's one of the,
one of the Thi Oh,
[inaudible] Pepin elbow hobby lobby.
Oh,
he shot does a nasty body shot.
They take that dude.
He's throwing fucking heat upper cuts,
mixing his punches.
I call that mixing your punches up.
Tell John Wayne Bar.
It's called mixing your punches.
That John Watch the angle,
the corner is anything he's saying makes sense.
Does that make sense at all you have to do is draw a diagram.
I will take my workshop,
Bro.
I don't have room for you this weekend and next weekend.
There's a lot of hands on touching,
not a spiritual and emotional work.
Oh,
we have a good cry and hold each other's
hands on.
We do.
We do not wear pants.
We have a strict page.
No pants policy.
It's like Nike but soda.
Well,
the first class is called [inaudible].
It's like Nokia first class.
It's called I fuck guys.
Okay.
Apparently there's 10 super volcanoes that can destroy the world.
10 Jesus Christ is the one in Japan.
There's one in Columbia,
the conspiracy theorists,
a geologist.
Right
blow.
Fuck man.
You get him to go to Mexico.
They have one in Mexico.
Most scientists are saying,
come on,
shut the fuck.
Yeah,
he's still got a couple of million years down.
Happens Mount Vesuvius.
Well,
it's kid.
They've killed a fuck load of people.
The Alex Jones of volcanoes.
Can you imagine?
What about Alex Jones got into volcanoes?
Forget the economy.
It's not about the economy anymore.
I'm going,
I feel like the chances of it ending America of volcano is pretty low.
Well,
it's only pretty low because our lifetimes are very short.
Yeah.
You haven't seen Dante speak.
It's,
it's chances of ending America hold.
It's chances of ending America are 100% it's 100% over the course of the entire,
over the course of the next 200 plus thousand years,
it's 100% that makes sense.
So it's
not whether or not it's going to end America.
It's fucking going on in America.
It's just whether or not you're going to be alive to see it happen 100% or
whether or not there'll be society at that point.
And whether or not we've been hit by an asteroid already all be on Mars by that
could be,
could be on,
I never know why.
Why do you choose Mars?
Well,
it's the only one I hear that we're exploring right now.
So the one in Indonesia is the one I think that they believe killed.
So many fucking people did.
That's why when they do like a genetic lineage,
when they test,
you know people's genes and try to find the unique origin of mankind,
they believe it all comes back to this one group of people that survived the
Super Volcano that blew 70,000 years ago.
So sleep tight there.
Venice Abbot,
Kinney,
fight club.
What happened with South Africa being the cradle of civilization?
Well,
that's where people started for sure,
but they move.
Oh Damn.
That was a beautiful left hook.
We're talking so much shit.
We miss that.
Well,
we're talking legit.
We're trying to tell people,
get your shit together because it's not.
Keto is about the bloating.
I'm telling them,
it doesn't matter.
Even if you get your shit together,
if you live in America and it happens,
most people are dead.
It's a continent
killer.
Mike,
my father used to ruin everybody's Day.
We'd be opening presents at Christmas.
He looked up from his book and Go,
and the 1930s,
13 million people died of starvation in the Ukraine.
Enjoy yourself.
Go back to his book.
I was like,
oh,
fuck off.
Is that a real number?
It would just make dot.
Well,
if you look at the greater area of an before World War Two,
when Stalin starved the Ukraine,
the number is crazy high.
Um,
and I think overall,
if you consider Latvia and all those areas of Baltic states,
it's about 13 mil.
John Wayne Park,
when you,
I'm sorry to change subjects here,
but when you're watching MMA and you're watching like striking,
you know,
we were talking about this earlier with Eddie Bravo,
we're talking about Jujitsu positions.
Like,
do you see these,
these positions that people don't capitalize on?
Like what level do you think like MMA striking is at now?
It's not,
it's obviously not the level of the highest level Moy Tai,
but like what,
what do you think about MMA striking?
Oh,
I think it's amazing.
Uh,
some of the guys that,
Luxor,
Ronnie,
I left [inaudible] he said he's so good.
Uh,
and then yeah,
it's just different because you guys can't stand and trade.
They can't go to toe to toe and he kind of just keep letting the bombs go.
Otherwise you get taken down.
Right.
So,
but I respect these guys so much.
No,
of course you do.
Of course.
He wanted to compete in MMA.
I did.
And then I broke my finger and then that's why I came up with my,
a new promotion with the Cajun Way Tinier because a Jaeger finger grappling,
I,
Yay.
I did my very first class and I broke my finger 120 more.
It's not a,
I do wonder gt class and burnt my finger.
So it's like how can I put in the cage but not dude,
you did to cause I don't want to break any more fingers.
And then now that's hilarious.
That's when I thought,
well stuff it I'll do an occasional times they'd
hmm.
And you've never wanted to go back to MMA?
Well now I've got my,
um,
that desire to fight in the cage.
True what I'm doing now.
And then I'm not going to be good at it too because I'm not doing bad at more
Thai.
What's that difference between fighting in the cage and fighting your ring?
If you could just going to keep it on your feet.
Ah,
I've also incorporated the MMA gloves as well.
Look at this.
So yeah,
it's,
it's everything.
It's everything MMA.
So as soon as you go to the ground,
you'll stop and stand back up and then you start banging it again.
She got down in the Clinton,
thrown in there like a,
you can in the moist.
Why clinch,
but you can't sort of suplex.
Okay.
And there's a cancer as well,
so we let it,
I can't.
So if you get knocked down,
there's still a chance you can still come back and still win.
So yeah.
But it's very violent.
Oh,
I looked it up on youtube.
The guys are fighting in the cage with boxing gloves on and looked very
peculiar.
So I thought,
you know what,
I have to be in such a big fan of the UFC for so long.
I couldn't put big gloves on.
I have to do it properly.
So what would you think about guys fighting bare knuckle and MMA?
Do you think that makes any sense at all?
Yeah,
too dangerous hands.
My hands is break your hands.
My hands are screwed.
Right.
But for like for realism,
you know,
because a lot of the reasons why people were able to just on low with a bunch of
punches is because they have gloves on.
Right,
true.
True.
Um,
yeah,
the damage.
But to be sustained and to try and get insured,
would it be quite difficult because the hands and the hand doctor on staff?
Yeah.
And just in case of somebody dying too,
you wouldn't want to see someone dying.
Then your promotion,
especially if you're the promoter,
had he put your head on the pillow at night time knowing that someone's died on
your show,
when you think that would make people die more often with no gloves,
I would think that would cause more decrement.
The grand and Pam would with no gloves on them could be quite severe.
Hmm.
I wonder man,
cause I feel like you can shin kick someone in the head with no pads on and need
someone in the head with no pads on elbows with no pads.
They mentioned it true.
I just don't think that it would.
I think I track,
I retract my last segment.
[inaudible]
no glove on your Shin right to the face and that's okay.
I've seen you can't do it with your fist.
I've seen you kicked dudes.
I've seen you kicked dude's you kick.
I mean it's just ridiculous.
The idea that anybody can punch as hard as you can care is ridiculous.
There's not a man alive that punches as hard as you kick that they don't exist
yet and you're crying,
you're bouncing chins off dudes,
heads,
blacks.
I mean,
come on.
The problem with being just getting it sanctioned,
right?
Cause UFC is just now getting out of like if,
if you're,
oh,
see that fucking his Momma,
the body Ray Leonard,
you know.
Yeah.
It was a Bolo Punch.
He brought it back,
brought it.
No,
you're right.
Brendan it with me and it's,
it's really,
uh,
you know that guy who was fucking helping keep a illegal in New York just got
arrested for corruption.
You know that right?
[inaudible] name mentioned his name.
It's like Satan don't match the old politicians,
those old crooked,
grubby fucking disgusting
little fucking carpet bagging.
Concentrate Bush,
those disgusting old men.
Disgusting old men existing on envelopes.
Yup.
Fucking timeshares.
He's out.
Huge,
huge,
huge for the UFC that this guy's done.
Imagine John Jones,
Madison Square Garden.
God Damn,
dude,
that's not outside of the wrong possibility at all.
I mean,
we're going back there in April.
We got to go to New Jersey with great for New Jersey.
Good Jersey makes a shitload of money.
It's just right there.
He just,
you know,
cross the river.
When I fought in New Jersey,
we did all the press,
everything in New York,
New Jersey.
Yeah,
of course.
I mean,
why would you not?
You're right next to the,
one of the greatest media empires are one of the greatest media locations in the
world for the,
you know,
for the east coast.
I think off I lost that fight.
Who the fuck knows you?
Barely.
Yeah.
Van Attention.
Oh,
I was watching how he's lost the fight.
For sure.
You're,
you're correct.
Yeah.
Was we did get mounted.
That's,
yeah,
sure.
He's been taken down.
That was amazing.
Martine's was a mounting him right.
He's taking them down.
Yeah.
That's,
say Tom was beautiful though.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the first John Wayne,
do you have to,
um,
do you have to constantly keep your shins,
uh,
num oil?
Do they,
once they,
once you kill the nerves,
they just never come back.
I've been there.
There's a old wives,
totally waste.
Basically hit your shins with the the every day.
Keep calling.
He's a coke bottle from Mexico.
I'm failing just kicking the heavy bag and lots of fights and you slowly,
you Shane guys flat and hot and condense then yeah,
no dramas anymore.
Can I touch your Shin there?
Is that what I show?
[inaudible]
that's a big shift.
We know what they say that it's like you get these little micro fractures like
tiny little microfractures all over the outside and those microfractures you get
a little blood in it and that blood calcifies then the whole thing almost
becomes like a Shin Pad.
Like you ever see that video of lion fights where Malik pet was fighting this
guy and just started going Shinny Shin with them.
Just smash the guy.
They'd shouldn't he Shinta check to kick.
The Guy did mal pet through kicked the Guy Shin checked it and the guy started
limping and so malpedas smiles at him and goes charge.
I'm just go Shin Shin with them over and over again.
Smash smashing his shin like he didn't feel it at all.
Oh,
it's like he's wearing this giant armor plated shiniest and he's got those giant
fucking calves.
Anyway,
those tie calves and giant shinbones,
those Kellen calves,
calves gets the opposite.
Put that away when I'm out of that.
When guys are starting at the very pointed Sean,
John and then um,
yeah.
Then the more you train and then slowly,
slowly I think I more,
more flat and then um,
where's your school?
Honestly does the potential
like a honest assessment check his hamstrings down the Hey Brian,
tell John about your taekwondo days.
Dot.
Okay.
Good.
Chai is we'll cake.
Well he had these forms that would scare us all my practice to have before the
competition.
Push my agenda,
my balls into my body wouldn't,
it was all Dick we remember that were guys who would say they could do that.
They would take ball kicks.
Well there's still,
there's like videos out there of guys taking ball kicks and it's like scientific
attempts to analyze like how they're able to take ball kicks.
Well they did the one on fight science
guys.
He's telling the story screen or something.
I think Morrie's created,
someone just gave them like a full kick.
I don't know it was,
but it's all and apparently it's the exact same thing where your balls become
like stones,
like basically front of your mind.
What kind of kids do you make with balls that had been kicked off in practice
repeatedly?
I heard a rumor.
It's the equivalent of a woman giving birth is when a man gets kicked in the
balls.
That's now don't kill me,
but that's what I heard for that quick instant.
It's a different kind of bank has been in the balls.
You get like a sick sick.
It's not just pain.
You got kicked in the stomach,
you got,
you got kicked in the liver.
It's that more than pain.
It sounds emotional.
Have you seen a woman giving birth?
Because I've been,
I've been up close and personal pussy tears apart like a moose that got caught
in a meat grinder.
Machine
joke.
Babies' heads are giant.
Vaginas are small.
Yup.
Just say,
hey.
I did start to worry about,
well I met a guy told me,
it's like I have a friend of a gay cousin Oscar the grouch with Ted.
Still the greatest line anybody ever say.
She's boxy dude.
She's boxy.
He's saying he called her Oscar,
she said between his girl and his girl makes her look like Oscar the grouch with
tits.
I couldn't stop laughing.
How's laugh?
I yelled it out at myself as I was driving home.
Oscar the grouch with Ted's.
Ah,
like two days later I'm text message.
Something that Joey Diaz would say.
How would he say fuck the box Oscar and grouch with tits.
Yeah,
but when does Liam Neeson old enough to be kicking people's asses?
65 now he's over and over.
I like that.
Keep showing old dudes doing great shit cause we're all going to be old.
It's actually,
let me see that it's going to benefit you.
You're young and beautiful.
Oh my God,
you're the primary Goddamn life.
I know.
Tear shit up.
Tearing Shit.
He just talking shit.
Looks Young.
How much longer you think you got to keep competing?
Man,
I've got a couple more this year and then we'll play it by ear.
The small
glove cage.
What are you doing?
That's amazing man.
What are you doing with that?
I'd watch.
What is that shirt you're wearing?
That's a friend of mine and he's a,
he's plugging it in.
Uh,
Australia.
Can you,
can you get in the clinch as long as you want a knee.
Can you do that?
Yup.
Let's break it up.
Ever when they clench,
when it's done,
it's getting stale and they look us as active.
But they'll let you work in the clinch.
Yes.
That's a beautiful thing because I think k one you can't work on the collection
side,
right?
That's where they can find Gloria.
They give him like five seconds.
Why are they doing that?
Doesn't it seem like it sort of water the damn boy toy and they try it.
They're trying to make it entertaining for the fans because getting in clinch
fighting is not as boring.
I guess the guys who are in the k one is change the rules.
But since more cow came the Kois and he started dominating people.
So the thing and now how can we make it even for the western as a vista toys.
I know we'll make it like the three second rule war when he rule well it
incorporates a lot of grappling.
You know it's obviously doesn't have any submissions and it doesn't have any,
you know any like take downs the way a wrestler has.
But that grappling position,
withholding that plum clinch and the way those guys develop that squeeze the
able to,
the ability to move a guy around.
It's much like,
you know like a guy who's like a really good next squeezer has that.
Just certain something.
Yeah guys get that with that Thai clinch man.
You remember when Anderson Silva locked up with rich Franklin?
Rich Franklin had never seen that before and then know what to do about it.
And Anderson was just so strong that position and he's compared to,
you know like the great ty,
he's like a bull cow.
Like come on man,
he's not,
you're not even close.
Know is not,
is not even close.
Not even close.
Wow.
You want to deal with like the,
the greatest tie fighters and their technique and the way they move and the way
that it can hold and not even close,
man.
You don't think so without,
oh,
without being disrespectful.
Like the claims that,
hey,
I didn't mean that was a very amateur.
That was a very basic clinch.
Barry just,
there was no,
there was no counter.
All they do was hold his hands down and just played,
not the die.
And he laughed at it.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
There's so many.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's hard for people who've never seen a like really great,
more tighter,
more Thai fights.
John,
how many fights have you been in total?
122 damn.
And then I had a 13 print books in four.
It's awesome.
Oh Shit.
But I had a throat,
a few composer as well.
I'm going to show you
what's the latest with Jeff Fenech Jeff.
Oh,
he's just doing his thing in Sydney.
He's,
I'm just doing promotions now and he promotes fights now.
Oh,
he's been fighting for years.
Oh.
So He's,
he transitioned beautifully out of boxing into promoting.
Yeah.
He's not in hunting as much as about three or four years ago.
He's chose run the POCs but in pretty much every week.
So He's,
he was very busy.
Yeah.
What about Troy waters?
Troy?
What?
I haven't had that name for you cause I gotta Fuck Terry Mars.
I used to be really into boxing.
I was a fanatic until the UFC ruined.
I'm looking forward to like have somebody who's been finding his whole life like
that.
Are you looking forward to retirement?
You're not dreading the day gotta be a hard,
hard transition.
I tried to retire a few years ago and the thought of it just drove me nuts and I
had to come back again because it was just killing me,
not being in front of the crowds and not,
um,
it was after parties.
Why after party?
That's what it's really about.
Laying in bed and not having that and she's a patient of,
of having a flight coming up.
It was just the,
I missed it so much that it came back again.
That's why guys who only have that feeling should fight.
Yeah,
that's it.
All these,
all these guys like I'd like to try one more time.
Like shut the fuck up.
You're going to run into some goddamn John Wayne.
Pour in the up.
Who Sleeps?
I like being afraid.
I like fighting the Goya is it?
I'm scared of.
Oh,
have you always been that way since you can remember?
Um,
yeah,
it was since I was,
it seems like a walk.
I've always wanted to be a fighter.
Damn.
It didn't matter if it was Ninjitsu karate.
I just wanted to fight anything and then just happen.
Kickboxing was near my house.
So that's how I started kickboxing in,
in Australia.
We're in Australia on the Brisbane back then.
But now I'm on the go cause,
but I moved to Thailand when I was 19.
I lived in Thailand for five years.
Wow.
So lived in Bangkok and then had,
I had about 50 fights in Thailand and Ford and all the big stadiums.
And when you speak Thai I do now.
Wow.
It's begun to jewelry.
Get it.
Like one of those Rosetta Stones Or,
Huh?
Cause I lived in toilet and I was,
there was no imagine living in California would know other people that could
speak English.
That was,
that was my lifestyle.
So he just learned it from talking to them.
Yeah.
I slept on the floor with 10 other people.
And then um,
and then I want to speak English today you'd have to do everything by hand
signals first.
But I had an aide or asleep.
Oh Wow.
And how different is Dutch kickboxing from Moitai that you learned?
More and more hands and more leg kicks.
Whereas the ties and more body kicks in and more knees and elbows.
Why do you think that is a different scoring system?
The toys don't school punching the dance school they kicks.
They cause it's harder.
It's harder to throw.
Body kicked in is a leg kick.
Anyone can throw laky so that and the toys in the clinching as well,
the clinching,
it would be good high score as well.
Isn't that an interesting that we don't think about that at all.
It was a scoring position.
We think of the clenches of almost being a stale stalemate position.
How do you score who get whoever can hold a plum clinch the longest live a
three's the last knee.
Say if you've got two guys try and 50 knees and the evening and even the unit,
the one who scores the last needs score is that,
that,
that rally.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So you see that you can be there for 10 minutes,
nee nee nee nee nee nee trying to break each other and the referee goes stop.
And that he's one.
That's it.
Wow.
But what if a guy knocks a guy out with punches?
It says,
if it's an lockout then then you're winning boxes them up and the guy is still
standing after three rounds,
10 punches and one body keep the body kick will win every time.
That's crazy.
Unless you Raymond Deca and then be that there's a different story.
So they're really,
they're really must be into body kicks.
Like to them,
that's the
most important kick.
Yeah.
Your body.
Can you go to Thailand?
It's a completely different contrasts of what you see here in America or in
Australia.
Um,
but it's so beautiful to watch two or what do you think about a guy like Simon?
Marcus is a really famous,
uh,
like really high level Muy Thai fighter and then he fights for glory.
They take away that clench,
you know,
they take away like what percentage of his game do you think gets eliminated
when they take that away?
You have to get back into the gym and readjust as well.
Cause I had the same as me when I went to Kaitlin.
Uh,
always thought of doing okay.
But it was,
I was losing it as well because I'd fight the Thai style and then I'd lose the
guys that are punching and it'd be like 30,
27 and it's quite,
hasn't hit me.
Oh Man,
I've kicked the shit out of him.
Right.
And then I was lost.
What the hell man,
Nathan Corbett,
he also fought in glory.
He fought Tyrone Spong and again,
they take away your clan should take away.
Yeah,
they'll be a lot of his weapons.
He's main thing is the elbow,
the elbow Kyla,
he's handling 55.
I know,
probably 60 fights.
50 50 or 45 knockouts and then 30th third of them are by elbow and then all of a
sudden they take us.
I was like,
that's so crazy.
Yeah.
This guy,
Nathan Corbett,
you never heard anything bad motherfucker,
but he looked a little like a little,
I mean not out of his element because obviously he's fought that style before.
But you know when you watch him with the elbows and the clinch and everything
and you,
it was really comfortable.
It feels,
but it feels odd seeing that that aspect removed cause it's still standing up.
It's still striking.
Like why would they remove?
That's like saying no opera cuts.
Yeah.
Sorry.
No body punches.
You only punched a white guy.
If there was no body punching,
everybody would just come out like this.
You know like everybody would have like super high hands.
Nobody would ever worry about their body.
You'd have a totally different thing and then you will let in body punching and
some guy's gonna come over and rip a left hook to your liver.
Like what?
Oh he wasn't ready for it.
He didn't know cause cause you don't allow them to do it and that's what you're
seeing with like glory and not allowing these guys to do like one of the best
aspects of striking.
And then with [inaudible] in general too,
like this is so hard to find a full Moitai show these days,
like full toy,
like five rounds.
A lot of the guys are gone,
three threes now for the promotions.
And then I think their main concern is if I do an elbow fight,
I bring someone from Thailand or Australia to America and the fight last 30
seconds and the guy gets cut.
I've just wasted 10 grand on a plane tickets.
And I say,
I said it's one of the big concerns.
Yeah man,
I get it.
But still just it's,
I think if you're representing martial arts like on television,
I mean they can do whatever they want.
The Japanese had their ideas.
We don't have to keep the same ideas as the Japanese with glory.
I think they should go with,
that's why I like lion fight.
I really like what they're doing,
man.
I like their full morning time.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm really,
I'm a purist as well,
so they can clench and which they,
they hold onto each other,
throw each other,
they'd dump each other,
they hold kicks and uh,
their whole little cadre kick and fuck.
Kick your leg out from under you.
John,
what do you think about the multiple fights in a night?
Single night.
Ah,
I used to do it.
You're a fan of it.
I've done a couple of them before.
I want a big one in Thailand.
In Bangkok.
Uh,
when I was younger I used to love him,
but now,
now I'm a bit older and the body doesn't,
repairs is fast in the breaks
anymore because when I was watching glory,
that's the main thing I was thinking about this guys who would have a battle
that first fight and have to back out and like Damn Joe Schilling.
Joe Schilling fought four rounds of Simon Marcus.
They go to the third round.
It's a draw.
They have to fight a fourth round.
He's got two fights after that knocks mark is out in the fourth fucking round.
Then he's got to fight Wayne Barrett and he's got to fight our Tim 11 and the
final fuck too much.
Yeah,
it's hard.
It's so,
Hud sees our Ferrara and Sam Alvey this a good fight.
The good fight.
What do you know about Alvey?
A Alvie was a contestant on,
he was on a team Carwyn on the ultimate fighter.
And I gotta be honest,
I'm surprised the kids here now because when he was on the ultimate fighter,
I was a guest coach.
He would quit.
He quit all the time and I was real.
This kid doesn't have it.
He got his training,
he got injured,
and then he came back for a little bit and he was their first pick.
He was the very first picking.
It did not work out on the show.
I was like,
go.
The kid doesn't have it.
Soon.
Went to MFC in Canada,
uh,
did great there,
and then got back into the UFC.
He won his last fight against Tom Watson and now Caesar,
the guy he's fighting,
uh,
I trained with for a while,
at the,
uh,
with vittores camp.
He's like little beat door.
So this guy's a freak.
Athletically.
He trained under Anderson Silva for two years.
He trained with Leo Machida and now he's Veit tours like pro DJ and he's such a
good athlete man.
Yeah.
I watched him fight um,
uh,
surge.
You uh,
what is his name for the,
for the title,
the ultimate fighter Brazil.
Sergio.
No,
it was him.
He looks thinner.
He looks a lot thinner than he did in the ultimate fighter.
This guy and I said,
yeah,
we went down.
He did.
He's fighting one,
eight,
five,
I think it was 2:05 PM he's gotten smaller,
I think.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
that's what it looks like.
Hi.
Where's the heart?
That's true.
They go,
we've got to come up with something for them.
That's,
he's on tits.
They're going to start throwing tens up.
Here we go.
His fighting style.
It's crazy,
man.
I don't think a,
I don't think the ginger has a chance here.
Big.
The ginger is tough though.
The man really sharp and his last couple of fights he beat Tom Watson.
You know Tom,
he did be Tom Watson on that different Amad though.
Caesar's a different animal.
Man.
Surgical Mariah.
That's who it was.
Try it was driving me fucking nuts.
I'm trying to remember his name.
Cesar is one of the best athletes in the UFC that I've seen more.
I choked out crone.
It was like the first guy to beat him when he,
when he got his black belt.
That's his background a couple of weeks.
Yeah.
Dude,
that was nice.
Yeah,
that Shit like a jab as fast.
You haven't seen mine,
but you get the off front kick.
He gets more comfortable,
man.
Fucking nightmare.
Oh,
another one hit 'em with the front body.
Speaking of body shots,
hey Sam,
go ahead and fly 17 hours of Brazil and fight a Cesar Mouton Day.
Enjoy this by me.
I like that.
Yeah.
He's just on that tough contract.
Speaking of tough contract,
I made a mistake last time I was on your show,
John,
the fight companion.
I said I got paid 10 and 10 or eight and eight.
It was actually 14 and 14 my bad.
Ooh.
I just learned that they just said,
hey,
please,
please let people know that you actually made 14 to fight.
They looked the Nogueira and I made 14,
14 to fight Mirko Cro cop,
my bad,
my bad Joe Silva,
Dana White.
Gotcha.
That's all it is.
There was no bonuses or anything else involved.
Uh,
I did get a bonus.
I was just talking about contracts.
I get up Toronto,
uh,
for knockout of the night when I thought Mirko Cro,
cop rich and she hit for that for that night.
For that night I bought a car.
And so what,
what is your football patty on exactly.
I never really got into that.
You did you play pro football?
Uh,
just for,
I'd like a cup of coffee with the buffalo bills and went back home.
Practice squad.
Yeah.
I played division one football for University of Colorado and then went to
training camp bills.
I was a tight in Hvac.
Got Good hands.
Yeah.
You got to say your,
your hands got to be amazing if you're a white guy.
Yeah.
Not Bad.
I mean,
be a white,
tight end and drop balls.
He's pretty fun.
I agree 100% right.
You're right.
They're not going to let white guys drop any balls.
You got to be a black guy and you could drop ball again cause you're going to
make it up later because white guys and really white you.
I gotta be honest.
It was the first time I realized that in sports it's a business.
When I got to Buffalo I was like,
Oh shit.
It broke my heart.
I'm like,
oh,
it's really not a team concept and they don't give a shit about me and it broke
my heart.
Man Really got back.
Oh he's thrown that.
We'll kick a lot through it again.
Alvey is yet to get something significant and trying to get,
he's trying to figure him out,
man.
Good luck.
How was your college career?
You a good eye for Colorado.
Yeah,
the gold helmets.
He started,
uh,
no,
I,
I w I worked in,
I had to uh,
a first round and second round draft pick ahead of me.
I'm a shit.
When you got to the bills,
like what was it that made it seem like I'm busy.
Business broke your heart.
Uh,
when you,
when when I got there,
I wasn't a draft pick as a free agent,
you know,
so you're basically like a body that they're bringing in and it was like they
wouldn't even talk to me and look me in the eye.
There's just like a 43 over there,
man.
Get the fuck over there,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
Just a Bot.
They don't give a shit about you.
They just don't have time for it.
They don't have time to be a friend now you got to understand that.
Right.
It's a business.
That was when I first realized,
cause you go from college,
which is about a team and hard work till you get to the NFL.
It's like,
oh we don't have anything invested in you.
Shit not dead.
Oh boy.
Huge wind for Alvie God damn shit out of nowhere.
Even with that left Hook Dude,
he was not shipped in.
Brazil's nice.
My Sam,
his fucking time biding his time.
Landed that left Hook and you're doing Caesar's.
Get light skin.
I think he has a girl or he did when he's on the show.
You know what the problem is,
is with would alarm me
as he goes.
Well my training camp every night to fight night in Brazil,
we spar so hard on Tuesday and Thursday night every night to fight camp.
When I heard that,
I'm like,
well that's an issue.
Your chance I can to hold up for too much.
It's already gone.
Dams,
two knockouts.
Cj.
Dot.
Yeah.
Galloway Galloway.
Now this.
Huh?
Cause he be Dalloway knocks him out and then Alvie with this left talk.
Watch this.
Oh,
that was sick.
Boom.
Oh.
Says Oh
wow.
That was nice.
It was shovel.
He even hesitated like Mario was going to stop it.
Look at that.
Right.
All that left shows nice sort of.
Oh it
wasn't too much.
Got Shut off for a second.
Yeah.
There was a
huge win for Sam.
He doesn't man.
Ah,
AH,
Z wouldn't know the smiley face hair cut on the back.
You see he has a smiley face.
Yeah.
I thought it was wearing,
he'll get him.
Damn.
That is dark.
We can those eyes.
It's gonna be a dark night for Caesar.
Kellen,
what'd you think of that?
I'm wondering if that's his sister or his wife,
but they look good.
Don't be rude.
I'm pretty sure that his wife,
I'm pretty sure,
I'm sure someone to tell me what he looks very happy.
Well,
yeah,
he's happy about to get weird.
Unless that's his wife.
That's when you get to win.
Maybe his wash the freak.
You never know.
Never know.
Let's hope she is.
It makes the story fun or that was a good fucking combination man.
Nasty.
That say's it.
Ferera guy.
What you said is giant where you said it's giant about those live where I was
reading interviews and he goes,
I'm not too nervous because it every Tuesday and Thursday and my camp is a fight
night in Brazil.
We spar so hard and went,
Oh,
oh Caesar.
He have so much talent.
Don't do that chatty.
Pronounce my shit.
My Shit.
Yo talk when you hear that good Joe.
He's like the old school,
uh,
pursuing the top team and stuff like that with wanderlust was beating the shit
out of each other in practice and taking,
yeah,
they shoot box guys.
Yeah.
Shoot box presented top team.
They should go hardest
knocking each other out.
Oh yeah.
It's weird.
They didn't know John before.
Uh,
before a match.
How hard do you spar a boxing?
About 90%.
And I understand and then type we just play.
Yeah,
just feeling each other out.
You know,
you're not really not taking hits to the head nine in Taco Moitai you just play.
What do you mean?
In Thailand we don't even,
where she in peds is so controlled and then you know,
if he got hit you can,
you can place your Shin across.
You're going to go out fast and then last I can pull it.
It's like being a martial artist says how do that to pull a shot the just to let
go.
So it's actually a good workout today.
It's so much fun.
And then you're smiling and then end of it.
No one's hurt,
no bruises.
You're not limping.
And then you're still friends.
Damn Dude,
I had to,
I feel like though,
when you,
when you up the pace in a real fight,
it doesn't,
it isn't it hard
to kind of make that adjustment because you're going so hot on the peds and,
and when I box spa,
I'm getting my workout because I'm trying to really hit my mate who I spoke with
regularly and um,
uh,
but,
and there's no hard feelings and when we box,
but I don't know,
just the Thai style,
it's just the way they do it.
And it's just you,
you don't say much on the pads and,
and the bag and then the clinching that you used to working with technique by
the time you get to the spine pot.
Wow.
That's interesting man.
I think that's a smart strategy for someone who fights a lot too.
Cause the ties would fight pretty much every week.
And I've had longevity.
I have no injuries.
You don't need to get tougher.
You know how to spar and take kits.
You know,
you're tough enough when you get to that level.
So it's just about repetition,
getting comfortable.
The erroneous assumption,
right.
They'd like fighting training hard.
He's going to make you tougher.
No,
you're at that level.
You're already pretty tough.
We don't need the challenges that,
that train since then when they buy it,
they get pretty crazy and then,
but they think of it,
well if I get hit in the spring like this,
when I fight,
there's going to be new in the shock.
But the Dutch go harder.
The legs and the body and they kind of lay off the head a little bit.
And some camps,
yes.
And then like Mike's gym,
they're known for knocking each other out.
Jim Cole,
Mike's Jane Golden Glory,
right.
Golden Glory.
They knock each other out.
Not Bad.
Well there's,
you know,
you're dealing with,
you got 18 murders in a room together.
All do.
They're all padded out.
It just takes a little bit of education.
Like whoa,
it's not going to work on some of those dudes.
God just got here from Morocco.
Leader is if we don't play that game,
son.
Yeah.
And then I'm running a family gym too.
So I want kids to come in.
I like the parents are watching on what and then the feel comfortable with,
I can walk away with it.
The kids getting knocked out cause so when you have young kids spar,
when they first learned how to spar,
what do you,
how do you emphasize like the playful aspect of it.
They see us doing that and they just want to copy and I tell him to okay before
we start,
everyone's going 10 15% they're higher than 20% otherwise you can sit out and
not play.
And then um,
and then I'll just keep keeping on him as well.
He just make sure he 10 15% no harder than 20% that's beautiful.
And then when they want to go hard,
you hit the bag,
you hit the pads.
Yes.
Your work,
your technique,
you understand your timing and your confidence.
And then he still looking at timing with aspiring to,
he's still for hundred fast.
These still,
you can again just go slow.
You're not going to name your shot so you're still a bit and then just said
you're laying on the ribs are their thought or even across their neck.
Just pull it back but just landed there and leave it there for a second.
Make sure everyone sees first and then take it down.
That's a smart way to do it.
But do you think they could do that with MMA because you're dealing with take
downs and you have to be really quick with your sprawl.
You have to be quick with the transitions between grappling and striking.
Do you think it's possible to do that too?
We were just still just pulling back on everything.
Um,
I've got to work with George Saint Pierre for two weeks and then that's a weird
play.
We wouldn't go any higher than 30% maybe,
but we were just,
um,
the,
the whole time we've been than control
kickboxing,
remote control robot that had punches that had like balloons,
like when they land there was a balloon fucking and,
and you can really hit the what not seriously.
And you can hit this,
this,
this robot is hard as you can.
So you're throwing hard punches and it's throwing legit.
It's legit.
Uh,
not as legit as Megan right here,
of course.
But it's going to happen.
Probably some really good trainers.
The guy who controls it,
that would be like,
you'd have to be really good at it.
You know,
video games to be a great child.
Like you could take someone who could never kick your ass,
but they get pilot a robot that can kick your ass.
So you'd go in there and have to do,
and then they would seek out to be guys with the best robots and the
robots way before they mfi robots.
There'll be sparring robots.
Think about it.
How cool would that,
isn't is the movie already
Jack?
Really?
They're sparring robot.
Well,
they were giant robot each other.
They didn't fight people.
When you're talking about sparring robots,
keep it real and mixed martial arts for boxing,
for kickboxing up for the striking arts in general
coming out and what's going on with his facial hair.
I like it some this is that really his twin brother might be faking it is Edson
face his face.
He looks so different.
I never seen him do look so different with a beer.
Harry looks first.
We'll kick Kao ever in MMA history Edson,
but well,
at least in UFC Johnson he started as a wrestler or was he,
if I kick her first wrestler first,
it was crazy about that cat knockout was,
I kind of called it and I said that if he's the only way he's gonna he's gonna
have to take some risks,
but if it takes a rest,
he runs the risk of getting knocked out.
Like,
as I said out,
he was out cold.
Like literally as I was saying,
knocked out.
He's dead,
stiff flying through the air on his back.
It's crazy timing.
Crazy ridiculous timing to say that total dumb luck.
But what a wheel care.
Who the fucks all of that coming.
Probably the best knockdown in UFC history right up there.
Cro,
cop,
Gonzaga Pedis.
Joe Lozan.
Um,
that's,
that was fucking sensational head kick.
But I'm talking about Edson and Terry.
Adam,
just when Terry,
Adam was just,
I was like,
Oh shit that's in killed the guy dead stiff.
I thought he killed her.
There's a bunch of cro cop Gonzaga.
So crazy.
Cause no one thought Gonzaga would win that way.
How's Gonzaga gonna head kick cro cop.
He think of all the cro cop highlight reel head kicks.
How the fuck has guns?
Zaga back son Cro cops thrown Gonzaga,
right?
Yup.
He's fighting Gonzaga and Poland rematch.
He's back.
You know why too,
right?
Why?
Because they were talking to him was Bella Bella toes talking.
Oh,
and the UFC said not so fast.
Not so fast.
Do you believe that relationship,
what's called copy talking about
fade or signing with bill or,
well he,
I mean physically signing autographs.
Rebelling.
Oh Jesus Christ came,
he scared the shit.
I would like,
look,
I'm,
I'm not,
uh,
you know,
I'm loyal to the UFC,
but I would not be angry if they sign fade or,
and Brock,
have they signed fado versus Brian Browse on Bellator.
That'd be,
I heard Bob talking about concussions though.
Yeah,
he's talking about concussion supposedly.
But that's according to like the pro wrestling guys who knows what angle they're
plan.
You know those guys are always,
there's so much showmanship and craziness in the world of pro wrestling.
Like I'm starting to understand that better.
Being friends with Tony Hinchcliffe cause he fucking loves pro wrestling and he
never stops talking about it.
I kind of just tend like they play things out in advance like way in advance for
like long periods of times we'd have these timelines.
You storylines they follow like soap operas.
Yeah,
exactly.
So when he says,
yeah,
Brock's worried about concussions,
they might have some crazy match that they're setting up.
We're Brock is scared to get hit in the head and they start talking,
he's scared to get hit in the head and they and Brock runs away like holding his
head.
You kept anything those guys don't scripted.
It's so weird to me
how grown men get into,
they get into it.
Dude,
I dated a girl who was super into it and it's hard to take her serious tip.
It's off fee after you did it grow,
do you throw wheel kicks,
jumping,
spinning.
Becky's,
there's sort of like a look like I only if I'm running buddy,
it's an inside joke.
It's all right.
It's crazy inside.
If I'm winning
I'm not going to lose sort of thing.
They're not throw it just for show for the fans.
But if not,
I wouldn't throw it.
I make sure I'm running for this.
Okay.
So that's something if you're beating the guys asked you might throat like a
slam dunk.
He doesn't only do it if you know that you can easier to pull off like stuff
like wheel kicks when you're adding and all the other shit like take downs and
all the other things like so it makes,
it's like there's so many variables then maybe get it off.
Whereas like if you're fighting and Moyie Thai and he got all the,
the leg kicks and all the things you could do much quicker and faster to land,
but it's like less high percentage that way.
The,
the main train is just trying to stay away from him.
That ties would never do it.
But um,
yeah,
they never throw wheel kit.
They,
they Manson Gibson used to throw them right back in the day.
That mother fucker out of vicious we'll kick but maybe they didn't throw him
because uh,
just because they didn't throw him doesn't mean they can't be really effective.
Right.
I came from that background and then we used to do them all the time and turn it
back when I was like 11,
12 and then I want to got to keep books and they said,
okay,
this ain't throwing any of these spinning kicks anymore.
It's too dangerous.
You got to stay front of him the whole time and keep it,
keep it basic and Rancic front.
People getting knocked out when they started spinning.
Is that what,
what happened?
No.
What did you see?
Um,
the last glory you see Gloria,
it's Nikki holds can fought Raymond Daniels.
Raymond Daniels,
a famous point fighter.
He's got wild,
crazy kicks.
He's got one of the nuttiest knockouts in all of kickboxing.
He throws a jumping sidekick.
You've seen me do it on a bag before.
He just throws a jumping side,
kick,
touches the bag with one leg,
then spins in mid air and spinning back kicks the dude in the face.
Who's crazy?
That's crazy.
You've seen it.
Brenda was ridiculous.
Raymond Daniels is a bad motherfucker.
See Nikki holds skin,
swarmed him,
got right in front of them.
Power punches to the body,
leg kick,
leg kick back leg kick power punches the body and just took them out.
Just took them out.
But basically get the base.
You have to basically kept in his face too.
So the pressure,
no room to spend.
The one time that Raymond Daniels landed,
he dropped him.
He dropped holds can with a spinning back kick butt holes and got back up.
Smile and good fucking yeah,
it is ranked number one,
right?
Holsteins number one and number one.
Yeah,
he's,
he's an ass straight bs.
He's an animal.
He's not the champ though.
Valtellina the other animal.
Well him and vaults Illini fought.
It was a really good fight up to the last round and he knocked belts,
Laney out faults.
Eleni was trying to come back and uh,
trying to like trying to,
like,
he was really being aggressive in the final round and that's when a Holstein
caught him.
He's a Dick.
A student to Nikki.
Yeah.
For him to go and go.
Is there any tie guys dedicated?
Sorry,
I'm sorry.
I was going to,
I don't want to talk over you didn't he dedicated his fight,
his last fight.
He's dedicated it to Ramona thing.
I Raymond died if he easily could.
Yeah.
Maybe before then everyone they indicated that they know is the cop.
They gave him some sort of a,
of some award.
There was some sort of a Ramon Dekkers thing,
but I don't know.
Were you gonna say,
I forget.
I met God.
You made me forget.
Sorry brother John.
In all your,
your years have a,
especially in Australia,
has anyone ever picked a fight with you when you're out a night?
Never.
Right.
They just know
there's some people that attracted I think because I'm so sort of just,
hey,
you're going and smiling.
I don't want to track a bad trouble,
I guess.
Otherwise they go out and they kind of hope it never it every Sunday there you
get punched in and someone else say,
but for myself,
I'd rather,
I'd rather have the joke and boy it would be it and trying to get in,
cause you're not getting paid.
You're not getting famous.
You've got to jail.
What the hell?
No upside upside.
Getting famous.
Notice what he didn't say.
You're getting hurt.
You're not getting famous.
You're just fucking guys are a guys that are famous for spa or there's gotta be
some wild,
unorthodox tie guys.
A few of them that are throwing a lot of spinning crazy kicks that are not
traditional.
It was a guy called,
some of that comes in.
He went in the first ever gold medal in the Olympics for boxing.
And before he went to boxing,
he was a boy and he was a spinner.
He'd spin the oboe.
He's been back.
He wasn't a very successful,
he was assessed with the back elbows,
but they're,
the backings of the ties was him coming.
Just didn't keep them in the bomb and push him over and teach them in the bum.
Yeah,
yeah,
Frankie.
Yeah.
It just takes too long and just spin.
Spin is just,
you just see it common.
You're like,
wait,
you got to spend.
He was hands on how fast it wasn't.
It wasn't like a proper taekwondo in Spain.
It was a tight spin.
So is there a big difference?
A lot of taekwondo spins or were used as defense as are coming into
and
your spin on Youtube and yours is insane.
So yeah,
yours would be a lot different to the ties,
but if you saw Brian's,
you would agree with the ties.
I was just saying that shit ain't going to work.
Hey,
don't do that shit because on youtube you guys and I was wearing a wig.
I don't want to that style dude.
You're seeing a lot of guys do.
Is that at that point styles?
No power to it.
That's the problem.
So loose.
They,
my nickname in MMA,
they called me butter guys like him away.
He hits the bag and he falls away from it like of the bag.
Faint forces his body away.
I pulled my route balance,
same inbox in,
they'll right love those Olympic guys who are gold medalists,
they don't translate to the,
to the pros because they have a kind of a point scoring system and these pros
are knocking mother.
It's not going to do to all about hitting the bag when it comes to kicking,
it's all about hitting the bag.
All those karate guys that you see throwing kicks in the air and they never
heard anything.
They never developed the,
the ability to shift your weight.
They're like,
you know when he's throwing a punch and you like,
you know at the end of that punch,
you fucking,
you're hitting things all the time.
You're hitting me,
you're hitting the bag.
These guys are throwing kicks.
They're not hitting anything.
That's the number one problem with a lot of these traditional martial artists.
They don't,
they don't hit things.
You man,
why he appointed me Bro.
I had him kicked my bag and I lived.
I almost,
I almost cried.
I fell over.
I fainted.
I shut down.
He's not allowed in there anymore,
but he didn't grow up kicking things.
That's not true.
He grew up in a terrible taekwondo school that had him like throwing flippy
things in the air.
It's not range a statement.
Tell Him Brian.
I never saw him compete.
I was competing.
I have to find my library of video.
I'll show you all my trophies.
Well actually Chitchat.
Keep.
I gave my truck to Chairman
Mao,
Bro.
I had the melted down when I was traveling a local orphanage.
We were basically,
we were probably in the same wing classes,
which is so confusing.
I traveled all over the world.
Same Age,
same Aau,
didn't you?
I thought all style really?
Cause I was fun.
Merican taekwondo champion.
I wouldn't marry Ken Brown did that.
I did the WTF.
Dude.
I'm standing right here.
I haven't strapper strap there.
Never saw you.
Never heard of.
You.
Never heard of you ever heard [inaudible] level?
Do you?
Eddie,
you.
I would love to be very clear.
I actually wouldn't lie about winning.
Just don't think you,
I think you did taekwondo.
Don't think a blue belt or something at the time when you were in the national
office about we be using now.
You won the nationals as a black girl.
I fought.
I fought hard to believe the I in Iowa,
the American taekwondo championships.
I'm sure you can look,
this is so great.
We're watching this fight.
Your taekwondo,
Michael Jackson.
He's strong as your bride.
Oh,
Michael Johnson's coming.
Was that he?
Oh,
Ooh.
That test,
that Chen Dude,
he's trying to stay tagged a few times in the first round and Michael Johnson's
putting the fucking scare on him.
That was a hard left hand.
Cause if you sit back yet,
Barboza goes to town,
man
Johnson with the heavy shadow rapid both fast.
This is,
this reminds me of the ways to find tech,
but I created more.
Nice shot you.
You don't know.
When did you win with,
I don't understand.
Oh,
you didn't hit him with those double spinning.
A double spinning wheel kicked up fit.
We'll kick.
Oh Damn.
He's just stuff I used was and get some volume young Jim,
you can't set this pace for three rounds,
so you can't,
you can't.
Yeah,
but you've got a good point Brendan.
I mean they can't,
he can't go at it 100% for three rounds.
Oh,
is Johnson coming off a loss?
It,
these last places,
long layoff.
Yeah.
He had an injury is me.
Right.
I don't remember what it was,
man.
Didn't he lose the Tony Ferguson?
I think he's lost.
He beat Pete.
Tony.
He broke Tony's on.
He,
uh,
he checked the kick,
broke his forum for over a year.
Didn't he'll write the steel plate.
It was,
he had a lot of problems with this.
Put a steel plate in it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of problems.
Did he have the plate removed or a d keep it in there?
I don't know what's going on with that,
but he's back 100% more ferocious than ever.
Our boats was mainly more,
yeah,
that's a great reason against Tony Ferguson.
That's a great fine.
Okay.
That is great to be crazy.
Tony's train,
so goddamn hard.
Of course he is.
He's an animal.
I really loved that.
Able to Hilo fight,
that was a strong fight for him,
man.
It really showed us closure.
Tamp.
Michael Johnson's got some fast fucking hands.
He's really pressuring him,
man.
I think it's so smart.
But the pace man for three rounds,
he's the guy that in my opinion has come up the most striking wise since he
joined the black zillions.
If you watch him from the ultimate fighter though,
the Michael Johnson,
you see tag up Joe Lowe's on,
he's just a different striker now.
I agree.
Hit him or Mitro.
Barboza
yeah,
I'd say Johnson or mitre and with the black tea,
the trail.
And it's come a long way as well.
They have some rumble Johnson.
Shit.
Fuck.
What are we talking about?
Robert Johnson's number one real quick.
How about that?
Camps killing it and just say that.
Well yeah,
right left by Johnson man.
That right hook tagged him on a tempo.
He might be hurt.
Blackzilians yeah,
Richard Jones.
Oh yeah.
Mytrials why?
Shit?
Shit.
But he straight.
No,
he's straight.
There's nothing about [inaudible] farm.
He's more far more country,
country,
strong,
mature and I nine amateur and is down.
Well that's because he used to play in the hand at whole nice leg kick.
Oh,
nice.
Clean left hook by right at Bondai of Barboza Talon
kick you damn right Scott.
He's cut his eyes,
his eyes fucked up.
Use that when he was coming in and see that and when I say was pat kick is deep.
Always write about thank you buddy.
It's like he,
it's like you are a national champ.
Well I was even as a moist talking about you can't not respect guys who are on
this hard.
This is,
you can't not take your eyes off it.
This is insane.
When they let go.
How do you prefer like watching Moitai or do you prefer watching him in May now?
MMA style.
Really?
Wow.
I love,
I love butter.
Left eyes cut now got cut in both eyes.
That yeah,
that rat last right hook tag.
No respect.
Johnson's just no respect.
That's what Barboza has had problems in the first round.
I mean,
you think about it.
That's where I'm the last call,
Danny Castillo cracked him in the first round.
Had I'm really fucking hurt.
Donaldson.
Roni tagged with that Jab,
dropped him in the first round.
Uh,
Jamie Varner fucked him up.
That right hand.
If you're going to catch him,
catch him with punches.
He was all over Donald first round.
All over in that jab dropped him.
Oh yeah.
Donald dropped him and choked him.
Is he still with you guys know if he's still with Mark Henry just he'll leave.
He does some work with them.
I know he was in one of Franklin's last camps.
Yeah,
cause mark,
Henry's a straight fucking magician.
He's a mastermind in the sport.
Doesn't get enough credit.
You're right.
Is this 55 holy shit.
A big 55 man.
They're going,
what happens when these guys fight Anthony Pettis?
Like what?
Oh Pedis isn't sitting there.
Then you hit Panama's on another level.
We're not both these guys out.
He's on another level.
Yeah,
it seems like he is.
He's no wind up with power.
He's got that shit.
He's also his movement,
his liquor and a finish you in a sec.
He's fluid and he's a perfect example of a guy who learned taekwondo first and
then went to a guy like Duke Roufus who just is a Moitai encyclopedia who's also
been training MMA fighters for a long fucking time and knows how to put it on
his hand on cm punk.
Have you heard some of the people,
some of those fighters?
Man.
Kelly,
could you beat?
They still haven't decided who they're going to give them the timeline either.
I figured it out.
He wants a timeline.
I think he wants her to learn how to work really smart,
man.
I think what he's doing is the right way to do it.
Officially,
I don't even know.
He's training with Duke until he's ready to compete and he's saying,
I'm not talking about shit until just trying to,
that could be a couple of years I think be after you get a couple of years.
No,
UFC.
He's not like,
yeah,
let's sign you and you'll fight in three years.
No son giving him six months.
I don't know,
but
they don't have a timeline.
The,
literally,
he said he wants to make a big deal out of it.
You know,
they did this little announcement and he said he wants to train until he's
ready.
That's not three years.
I guarantee you the UFC is gonna be three years.
Do what?
Here's a fight.
Oh Shit.
Eric Soda.
Rashad Evans.
Somebody's not,
obviously that's an a month going Paris,
Hong Kong with a real name.
I mean a guy with no long time.
No,
they're going to pair a cm punk up with a guy who should never be in the UFC.
I'm not,
shouldn't be in the UFC.
I mean it shouldn't be in the UFC yet.
I bet you know the guy with like one.
Oh you think?
I bet they give him like a old washed up guy who's been in the UFC,
so we recognize the navy out of bed.
Everything owned right now.
And it was in the cm punk versus fallen Fox.
Who would you bet on?
Everything you own right now?
Sam punk over Fallen Fox.
Yes.
Destroying class.
Yeah.
Okay.
I,
Hey,
I would've picked a Sam punk too.
Damn.
Michael Johnson is still going hard in this second round.
Two massive man,
man.
He looks good.
Yeah,
he's not,
it doesn't have a strategic approach to this fight at all.
He's just trying to test Barboza.
I think it's smart man.
Trying to break his will.
I like it and he's,
he's already kept it.
Light kicks away because Barboza has been real careful about those counters.
He's hesitant landing nearly as many leg kicks is.
He has some really smart man and a South Pole to south park too.
Do you like when when you see south paws and MMA and it opens up that inside leg
kick?
Yes.
Yeah.
Got to stay really basic when you're putting this up.
Well yeah,
he's right.
Kicks in the right hands,
right hand left hooks.
You can't do the flashy stuff against says [inaudible].
It doesn't work really I believe saying no one you have of the Orthodox fighting
the south part opens up the back leg power kicked.
Oh right.
Because it's that soft side.
Yeah,
set it to the back.
But you can't,
you can't rely on you.
Sweet.
You can't use your front teeth as much anymore.
It's taken away a little weapons.
Who good body kick capture most body.
Why can't do damn he heard him with that left hand.
Why can't you use the uh,
the front teeth this month?
Oh,
oh.
Sitting down those punches that was taking the shine nasty.
Oh Damn.
That was a quick switch.
If Johnson slows down Barboza and start letting loose and letting loose of those
kicks because he good late in the fight.
Proposer Cardio.
It's better be better of Cardio Frankie Edgar and for the record,
cm punk would kick my motherfucking line had fallen thought if it went to the
ground,
don't get twist and I don't know that there's punches involved.
Anything can happen and we are the on the record.
Cm punk would fuck me up and he's got way bigger balls than me for stepping in
the cage.
If it's what I did.
I was just doing jokes on stage.
Big Guy.
False humility is hurting my feelings.
Slash.
Mom.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not saying that's not being humble.
If I bought cm punk,
he fucked me up.
Listen to pro wrestling.
He got me.
Fuck yeah,
man.
Dude,
I might even,
I might even fucking with you.
I'm,
that was me.
No,
I'm serious.
That was,
oh,
Jackson got tagged.
He got tagged,
Dude.
Barbosa just clean.
Oh,
there's Mark Henry.
He's in his corner.
That was a clean right hand.
Yeah.
You're,
you're going to be in trouble.
Uh,
you're going to get tagged.
Right.
You open yourself up being this aggressive.
Just a matter of time.
He definitely got tagged right there.
It's also a matter of a Barbosa Campbell,
the weather,
the store.
I agree.
Oh,
Johnson tag him.
Ooh.
Little wobble.
His legs are a little shaky.
Ooh.
He's trying to take him down.
Fucking old down.
Just that hour.
Thrown against the cage.
Some big heaving breaths here,
folks.
I think he was rocked there.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Oh my God.
He's on his back.
He's not good.
It's not good for eds and Blacktown Jujitsu.
I don't know,
man.
I don't remember right now.
I don't think so either.
A black guy,
I don't think exact belts.
If you're,
if you're an aggressive guy,
landing your cardio last longer than aggressive guy ever losing,
uh,
not,
not leaning as much.
If you keep leaning,
all of a sudden you,
I got him,
I got him.
He can kiss,
keep pump coming the rounds at all the time,
but as soon as you start,
lose the confidence gives you care.
As soon as she was just not missing anything.
Oh Shit.
I'm tired.
But why Atlanta every time you rock him too.
It's a purple belt.
Really pro Bono Jujitsu.
He works with Ricardo Almeida down there in New Jersey.
He's looking for that cake man who set up that head kicks.
Oh Dang.
Johnson's just common man.
Johnson's wearing the same John,
how come you,
you never saw Superman is oh damn.
That was a nice right hand too.
How come he never saw superman punches in Moitai very,
very rarely.
But you see it so much in MMA.
What is that?
I think the little gloves,
the little gloves make a hell of a difference.
Even,
even George,
when George Tourism,
they seems the rock guys heads back.
But you do that in 10 ounce gloves and nothing happens.
It's like boom,
all right.
Right.
It was funny.
What do you,
but you do an MMA gloves.
All of a sudden it's just rock your world and George,
that was off his jab too,
which is not a hard punch.
You're saying it's just kind of flashy,
frozen.
Not going to be a difficult Johnson.
Don't call him.
I ain't even know who you're watching.
So ugly.
Michael,
Mj,
Mj come in and you get to leg kicks from.
Yeah,
the number two,
Dan,
I just leaned into leg kicks.
Just say you guys know
when I trained,
just like fighting it in the Philippines.
The Philippines.
Yeah.
I was at a third place where your national champ fell.
That took place.
Took third place.
I had the virus,
had a,
I had a virus,
I had the runs.
So you're not buying this national champs stuff with [inaudible] hit thing.
Let's not get carried away with national chain.
That's what you told me.
There was a,
there was nothing called the nationals in Iowa in 1987 I can't remember exactly
where I'll find out.
I can actually find out.
Watch this.
Wow.
Hold on.
I'm going to find out.
I'll get you all the details.
I asked her,
I go to Twitter universe to pictures of Callen
when and no one.
Right?
Nothing.
I'll get all of it just doesn't make any sense that everyone that I knew from
back then doesn't know you have you either.
Well because they're all stupid.
What was going on?
I don't understand.
I'm to ask.
It was the 80s it was the late eighties.
We didn't have fucking made that.
No one's storage shit.
What was the,
I believe it,
it's just like what did you guys kick?
Did you just kick paddles or banana trees?
No bags.
And who did you fight back?
Do you have a name?
Um,
cause I remember everyone I five thought rich spelling.
I don't remember that.
I know the last guy following him asking me out and I know the guy I fought
beforehand cause I knocked him out.
But I know it's like a shit load of guys.
Right?
Like you're competing all the time.
The last year or two,
I don't remember.
I don't remember it.
You get two fights.
I remember Jack Mcvicker.
That's it.
Great.
And this fucking fight is crazy.
Jesus Christ.
Even a third round.
These guys are throwing man.
Oh there you went for it.
See any slips.
See I told him he shouldn't do that.
Damn he is throwing some fast kicks.
I think they are both Barboza he's down to,
there was a four header so we'll see what he says.
Okay,
well let's wait.
Would you say that uh,
Michael Johnson Kin,
uh,
can throw more kicks because he doesn't throw that many right?
Oh,
those are nice ones.
They bought in.
I'm sorry,
John,
I asked you a question.
I think we cut you off.
Like why?
What about the front leg?
Tepe what about the southpaw stance takes away the teeth.
If you all are standing Orthodox and you've got your left leg forward and then
your orthodox,
the left leg is going to go through it.
The center.
As soon as you going to set up,
all of a sudden this leg is going to check it and you can,
you can check your stomach because your stomach a lot easier.
So now everything's got to be off the right leg and said the front leg.
You know what I mean?
Atlanta flashy.
But as soon as I saying he and then all of a sudden I've got this like neon.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
Do you find that typically a midway?
I had 72 and a half.
And what do you walk around at 80 e five 86 oh Geez.
Yeah.
So in 40 [inaudible] you,
you,
you cut weight that just like a MMA.
Then I start 10 weeks out and so they go down.
So they go down and then lose probably the last five or six.
Jesus Christ,
this is our job.
This is a war.
I mean these guys are not fighting.
They're trying to kill each other.
This is a Johnson set,
a very aggressive pace.
It's still keeping it up.
Yeah.
It's almost like he's trying to prove a point or make a big statement.
That was a big kick to the body right there.
Who's winning so far?
How are those cases?
The body Johnson's not to not scored.
Same as punching you.
You really think Johnson up in that second round and I wasn't paying enough
attention when he talks to my two zero and he got that take down.
That's right.
We are in Brazil though.
Yeah,
and he did rock Johnson.
Would that one punch?
Johnson rock case control.
He's pushing easily be Brazilian easily.
Oh Dang.
That was a beautiful combination to Johnson is on fire.
Oh Damn.
So good kick to the body that he's trying to finish out of blood coming out of
the nose.
Over both a cam.
That's a hard kick.
How's he taking that rose?
That kicks so fast,
man.
There's so little windup.
Oh that's another thing John.
Like what do you think about like,
like a lot of these guys you've seen in MMA like Liardo they throw karate style
where there's no warm,
there's no step is no.
Like,
what do you,
what do you think about the varying differences between like the karate style
that you're starting to see from a lot of these guys and like Thai style?
I'm loving it.
I love the variables,
the versatility I like.
I love having,
um,
the culture of karate coming back again and all of a sudden it's showing that it
is an actual form and he's actually working.
I don't want to be a one person.
I'm only toy.
He's going to beat everything I like.
I like karate.
I,
let's see,
I like MMA.
Awesome.
If you can throw a,
an amazing spin kick,
I reckon it's amazing instead of the traditional,
yeah,
if you can do the cool stuff a
couple of way.
Well you know that opened minded probably one of the reasons why you became a
great fighter in the first place.
You were thinking,
you know,
Oh damn.
Barboza has some really fucking fast kicks man.
Super fast.
Like from the chamber,
like right from the launch,
he's throwing some,
not really land in Johnson's very aware and ready pressure man pressures.
Incredible.
And the ones that have landed Johnson's eating them well and countering,
Ooh,
take some crazy shots.
This just shows you like how high level MMA as these guys have dedicated like
their heart and soul for years to get to this point.
And both of them would get lit up.
But Cardio,
is there anyone take down attempt as well as the whole fight is?
It's pretty much pretty much um,
mostly stand up.
Yeah.
You're seeing that a lot,
man.
You're seeing that a lot.
There's many,
many fights ago by now.
It used to be very unusual if there was no grappling at all in a fight.
Now it's pretty common.
Uh,
I think that's because of the pressure from the fancy takes him down.
I think it's a number of things.
I think that's a number of things though.
If you,
if you're a grappler,
it's frowned upon John's Kallan was he kicking around this?
Right?
I would agree.
But as that master wheel kicker was kind of in a national national championships
national,
I mean it was kind of a national,
we can't just,
if you read the tech one of the times,
cause that,
and if you do,
you're a loser
Johnson one that Johnson won that fight.
Definitely.
At least two or three.
Nothing really.
I think three nothing,
but it's Brazil.
It might be a very impressive performance.
I'll tell you that he went after Chad.
Some of my hardest fights have been doing the cutter.
Is that right?
Is anyone taking myself?
So that's not as very personal.
Okay.
So what took that seriously?
What can I ask you this?
Do you ever use Open Eagle Claw here?
Look at that right there.
I did the Mac.
What do you guys think about the,
uh,
the main event here?
Frank Mir and big foot.
I think when there's only one guy needs to win more than I do.
It's Frank Mir.
Big Foot needs a win too.
He just got knocked out by her.
Lawsky here's my question.
Should be allowed to do in Brazil.
No,
both foot lost a cane.
Right?
He lost a cane.
He had a draw,
but then they took it away.
Tested,
positive sounding,
been tested positive.
He had a license to take testosterone.
They tested him before the fight.
He was one level.
They tested them after the fight.
He was off the charts.
So that means in the locker room,
hang it hat pride styles.
He's getting sued by his doctor because he's,
he tried to say that this was the doctor's fault that was doctor suing him.
So,
so he's really,
Oh and three mirrors.
Owen?
Four oh five.
Oh and for uh,
you know,
I don't think you'd say he's so in three after that fight with big foot or with
a Mark Hunt rather cause all due respect.
That was amazing.
It was such a fucking war.
Yeah.
Maybe he was on some chemical assistance,
but God damn,
that was a fucking war for sure.
But it wasn't a win.
So I would say,
oh in two.
Yeah,
two and one.
I'm going to say it's so fucking hard to tell him it's,
what do you,
what do you call that?
You either gotta say the fight never happened or you say was what it was,
which was a draw.
I don't think we sang it.
You celebrate it.
Celebrate it.
You can't sell it.
Well you could celebrate it as a performance though cause got down.
That was a performance by both guys.
So much so that I have a,
I have a roots of fight,
a very limited edition,
big foot hunt silver tube before the drugs,
the drug test came back,
came out classic.
They made this jacket and Dana sent me one.
We were laughing and he gave it to me cause he,
he loved that fight.
Taina love that fight.
And then when it turned out they got the drug test back and they found out that
big foot was through the roof.
It was so disappointed.
He was just so depressed.
He had these jackets.
It the classic.
Yeah,
it was a jazz make foot hunt too.
I was ringside
medio away from it.
Oh,
steroid problem and kickboxing.
Did we talk?
We didn't test.
But in Thailand that's not a problem then you've got a problem.
No.
Then you don't have a problem because you're not really caring.
I would say it's an issue you say.
Would you say in your opinion,
uh,
what,
what do you think?
Let's say pride or the pride biters and all the pride fights.
Would you say the number would be 70% of pride fighters were on something 80 90
or a hundred what would you say?
What would you say it?
I can't say I did a pri back then.
I don't know if you had to guess based on the things you hear when I talk to
ensign anyway,
who fought in pride and didn't do shit,
he didn't take anything.
Have you talked to him?
I bet.
I bet he's right and most people,
so probably most seen means like 70 60 70 something like that.
But he said it was in the contract that they don't test for steroids.
They wrote it down in the contract.
It's weird.
I think MONTCO was a prime example of someone that might've done something
to dissolve my nose.
All positive thinking.
Mark [inaudible].
I dunno about Kirk.
If he woulda did stories,
he would have been huge.
Same with Ken shamrock.
Mark Coleman.
Yeah.
So,
so the reality is the reality,
as we know,
probably pretty certain if you had a bet,
all the money you had,
you would go,
yeah.
Most of the pride fighters,
maybe 90% maybe you'd have to go with that.
And no one's questioning their legacies exactly at all.
No,
it's quick.
And we know they were,
they promoted it,
they put it in their contract,
but it does.
No one tested positive.
Once people test positive,
then people get angry,
then the trolls come out.
Then people share their opinions.
Then people write all these fucking pieces about it and then then it becomes
like,
it becomes a real thing.
Nerds that sucked at sports that are talking shit.
No,
it's a lot of people that are like,
you know,
they're purists.
They don't want to see that shit,
but it's always been in,
in every major sport.
We're pretending that it's not around sports.
Going to be more accepting of it.
Like you're gonna be like,
Hey,
the guys on shit,
whatever.
He's still a great athlete.
If you've never compete in sports and you stick behind a computer and eat
Cheetos all day,
you're like,
this is ridiculous.
That's why they're better than me.
It could have been the NFL if I did the same shit.
Oh really?
Go take the same shit and trying to get baseball.
Like baby.
Yes.
Everyone's pretending,
right?
Yeah.
There's a lot of,
that's what's going on.
Everyone's gone.
Okay,
let's pretend test.
We're going to have a pretend press conference.
We're going to have a pretend news fucking media thing.
Everything's pretend testing is fucking for real.
They're spending a shitload of money.
The conferences,
the press conferences,
but everybody that's testing everybody's involved.
They know the reality.
The testing is just to somehow make it look like they care.
No,
no.
The testing is to try to eliminate it.
The trusting is try to bus people and now they're going to give them huge fines.
Now they're going to kick them out for like two years,
two or four years.
Right.
Like Dana said,
I want my four years and let's make man,
I don't know about any of that.
That's what they're doing,
but nothing's,
because I hear they have to kind of do it and have to kind of say it.
They have to.
They have to do.
Everybody want to do it.
They want to clean up the sport.
I know this from the top down.
They do want to get the steroids at a sport because it's bad for their business.
If these guys can get tested positive for steroids and it keeps showing up and
all these new,
it becomes a part of the store that makes it unattractive to advertisers and
makes it look like what the worst stereotype is.
This thuggish sport that's filled with criminals and people doing unethical
things and the Lance Armstrong and and all that Barry bonds,
yet everyone's still doing more cycling.
Everyone's still doing it right,
but that's what they're trying to eliminate.
How else would you have him eliminated with random testing?
The time to catch then everybody isn't there.
What do you send that Victor content but wasn't he saying when he said that they
got steroids now that get out of your system really quick and that's what
everyone's really on is the shit that gets out of your system within days.
And they're just taking chavy Lance Armstrong.
He just said like on,
isn't that what he's saying?
And His podcast or maybe I heard wrong,
but apparently podcast with me.
I don't know if it was yours over it again and listen cause we talked about a
lot of parents.
Have you heard of this?
Have you heard that there's like steroids,
they get in and out of your system really quick,
right?
Yeah,
right.
But I don't think financially guys,
a lot of guys in the UFC and beat afford those.
That's like at a high level you're talking about Lance Armstrong talking about
NFL guys probably deal.
So there's,
there are different steroids and get out of your system really quick that are
super expensive.
That's what I've heard like,
but yeah,
like there's steroids that they're ahead of the testing.
Well,
you know when I feel like he was a guy that would know because he was a part of
that whole thing with the clean,
they would put that,
that would,
it's like a gel they would put on these guys and they would,
they would pass all their tests and that's what's what the balco scandal was all
about.
Was it designer steroids that they create it.
So if that's what he's saying,
I mean that makes sense that this,
you know what's going to eliminate it?
The UFC doing random testing.
He's going to fuck guys Brendan.
But,
but listen,
it's great what they're doing.
They still,
in your opinion,
do you think professional football players,
uh,
do steroids don't eat into the microphone.
You think they do social after all this shit,
you still have professional athletes still doing it after all the time.
He's going to be a part of cycling.
Are they still doing it?
100%.
So how are they going to clean it up in MMA?
Technology's going to just possible technologies is always going to be ahead of
the testing.
I wouldn't say it's impossible,
but you can catch guys.
What are these?
I think they're,
I think it's,
I think,
I don't think anybody should be trying.
I think it's just a show.
But,
but now is it a show Eddie?
Cause now if you get caught dancing,
you're out two to four years.
If you're a uh,
Roy Nelson or Brendan Schaub and they tell you out for two or four years,
you're done.
You're done fighting.
So are you going to risk taking steroids?
The,
if you know your,
he's the harshest laws and professional sports,
that's what they're trying to get done as that what's going on at that point?
How can,
how come I never got to that point in football,
they're still in it.
A true [inaudible] doesn't have a state athletic commission behind him.
Like Nevada.
Is that what's going on?
Absolutely.
100% so football doesn't have a state.
I don't have to have a state athletic commission or fights.
They self test.
They like to,
why the NFL or the NBA doesn't test for pot.
They may make it in their contracts.
It's,
you don't have to deal with the athletics.
They figured out a way to get around it.
No sports,
they don't have anybody to answer to.
Well they didn't have anybody
to answer to that.
You didn't.
Nevada state athletic commission sanctioned to UFC to make it legitimate cause
have was this crazy sport that was actually outlawed.
Football's never outlawed.
So football didn't need to be cleaned up to the point of where some regulatory
body consents to having them performing their state.
Also [inaudible] NFL,
those guys aren't punching and kicking each other in the face.
So there's a little bit,
there should be stricter punishment when it comes to fighting until you're
getting into punching and kicking in the face.
And I got it.
I didn't sign up for extra punching hard in the face.
I signed up for medium punching.
I didn't want to get punched really hard.
It doesn't make any sense.
You're getting in a fight in the cage.
You guys are throwing down.
I Dunno.
I'm not sure what you're saying.
I'm just saying that I think it's a big show.
I mean everybody knows everyone's doing shit.
You're saying they shouldn't do anything about it.
I'm saying all I'm saying they should if it worked for pride,
let them do.
I'm saying they have pride rules,
pride format,
pride.
A pride regulation.
That's what I'm saying.
I think that that's bad for the sport.
Was it bad for prime?
It did.
Did Pride
advertisements.
Yeah.
Pride.
One under dodge and Harley Davidson jumping on board,
but did it have to do with the steroid use the steroids made pride crumble.
I'm sure it was a part of it.
You can't have guys Jerusalem the Gills,
but how did that have to,
how did that correlate with the demise of pride?
I don't get it.
Cause guys have traps hanging out of their fucking airs,
punch each other lives,
so hardly dance like,
yeah.
Obviously that guy's not natural.
I don't know.
This is a false premise was what happened with pride was the Yakuza.
That's what happened.
There's a lot of problems.
First of all,
Japanese are different than us and they go in fads,
they have fans and sometimes those fads are gigantic.
Huge things like,
you know,
the,
they would fill 90,000 seat arenas with kickboxing.
Not Anymore,
man.
Really?
Yeah.
And just things happen.
Things change.
Yeah.
Nope.
Not until the mic and see how I do that.
People complained about,
well what about I promise I'll never do that again.
Back to him.
That's a probably.
What about,
what about Fidor do you reckon he was on something?
Um,
you know what,
until you know for sure you can't say,
you know,
but I would imagine the possibility is high.
He didn't look,
cause he didn't fuck,
he didn't,
he looked big fucking making me go back and look at what he looked like when he
fought Fujita go back and look at what he looked like.
It was a thick motherfucker.
He didn't look anything like you looked when he fought big foot.
Sova so what happened?
Did he stop lifting weights?
That's possible.
Or did he stop taking whatever the fuck he was tanking?
That's possible too.
Yeah.
When Anderson Silva test positive,
I would have never guessed.
I know what it never,
I would talk.
I,
I w I l everyone apology.
I told people John Fitch would never take steroids
because John Fisch told me that and I believed him
in your late thirties you're trying to compete in MMA with the,
I mean it's almost impossible.
Not only even know it ain't easy.
Well,
would you rate Fidor even better than he already is for beating guys at are on
steroids?
Yes.
Unless he was on steroids when you guys were on steroids,
you don't,
you don't know man.
Look,
he's obviously in the pocket of some very wealthy people who would want him to
do well at all costs.
I don't know what the ramifications of those conversations,
but I do know that I had heard unsubstantiated reports of how he got paid and
who got the actual money and you know,
he's dealing with some very fucking powerful people.
It went big when paintings at the show,
there's something going on.
There's a lot of other people behind the show that also were very wealthy and
you know,
look there's there,
there he is right there fader that fade or with big foot on top of him smashing
them as no,
no relationship whatsoever to the fade or that beat.
So many guys in pride.
He's also older though.
It is kind of personnel there might had his exemption.
Yup.
He did have his exemption.
He was huge back then.
He is all,
all those things are correct.
You're right.
But I still and mean he was certainly diminished because of just sheer training.
Trauma fights,
some high level fights against some big guys for a long career.
There was all that too.
I leave and changed his style of,
of training through.
He stopped with the weight lift.
I don't think sometimes guys just getting old,
they might not be on steroids.
Just get old washed up.
That shit happens.
We get punched in the face.
That definitely happened.
Yeah.
Can we go,
do you guys think Frank Mir,
big foot,
big foot.
I've got to go with Frank Mir.
I didn't like the way big foot went down against our Lawsky looked.
We looked crazy.
It looked like his,
his chin had evaporated.
Also taken frank man.
Surprisingly.
Yeah.
You're going Frank Mir from Joe.
Not For me.
For Frank.
No,
I'm saying you're going with,
yeah,
I'm going with mirror.
I think miracle win this fight,
but I wouldn't be surprised if big foot took it to him by submission.
Oh,
he could win by submission because big foot's never been submitted and he's a
black belt while he's giant.
I know.
Do you see one fader and went for that leg lock on his laugh?
He was like,
yeah.
I was like,
Damn.
So no,
no,
no laughing door.
I would just want to see frank wind.
Man,
he looks in good shape.
I mean,
I watch some footage of him training.
He'll say,
you worked hard for this.
He had Vicki Lynn down on his corner and did a lot of,
a lot of training with him.
A lot of work on his grappling.
Fucking hard man.
At this age,
it's hard.
You gotta realize frank was 22,
he's been fighting the UFC isn't tired life.
Yeah,
dude,
I was there back then watching it.
I mean,
I didn't get a chance to see the early ones in person.
I didn't get a chance to see him in person.
And like until
a boy,
I remember which fight it was.
Lessons maybe.
Well,
I saw,
I saw west Sam's for sure.
Um,
I saw the,
the uh,
Tim Silvia fight.
I was there for that,
talking to Tim in the octagon and we wanted to keep fighting and then we showed
them the video,
his arm getting snapped.
He's like,
oh,
and then you realize like,
and then the shock sets and you're like,
I gotta get to the hospital.
He thought,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I just appreciate what frank stands for and how long he's been doing it.
And he's relevant.
And my favorite UFC fight of all times when he beat Brock Lesner,
I felt like it was the MMA community against the WWE community when he beat him.
I never chaired for so and so hard in my life.
But how crazy is it?
Take a guy his second pro fight,
you make them fight a former UFC champion in his prime.
Great.
Ridiculous,
ridiculous.
Well,
Brock Lesnar got brought along worse than any fucking fighter ever in the
history of fighting and still managed to outrun the odds.
I still managed to speak of a freak.
He was,
oh yeah.
Beat Randy.
Go towards fourth fucking pro fight.
How?
What?
Ha.
[inaudible] knocked him out.
Beat heath herring and then he beats Randy coture third and fourth profile.
Are you fucking kidding me?
He gets submitted by frank,
right?
Yeah.
Well the second fight with frank.
Yes.
Frank,
submit them.
And then uh,
after a Frankie fights,
heath herring steamrolls he heath herring.
It's amazing how he remembers all this shit.
Got nothing else or now justified.
I don't remember anything,
man.
Just a couple of fights.
But that's not true because if you're talking about Jujitsu submissions,
positions,
submission transitions,
you could remember,
shit,
I see you go over moves and techniques.
I'm so behind the curve.
Oh,
that's different.
To start taking.
Like the odds are,
is bigfoot knocks him out in the first round.
That's the,
the highest thoughts.
Other guys out there that can know,
they know every,
like you could do a UFC trivia game or jeopardy where they know you could say u
of c 152 and that could just rattle off fans,
not fans for sure.
You're there.
I'm sure Joe's probably damn close.
Kenny Florian is really good too.
Kenny knows his shit.
Every UFC,
the number,
the headline or the Co headliner.
I bet there's some fans for sure.
Easy rain men can go into the prelims and give you that fucking results of the
prelims.
The Guy,
I call him the fight pass king.
He knows all that bypass guys out there.
We get right.
Have it a little uh,
UFC trivia podcast show once.
These guys are all pretty good.
Some guys get mad at me.
If I'm watching these and I don't know a guy,
I'm going to go,
I'm not working.
Yeah,
I know.
It's super upset.
Just watch him.
I used to know him all.
I don't know shit anymore.
I know big foot though.
Deal with a giant head.
But one of the things that I think they fucked up,
um,
they should have,
should have kept going was when you were doing those in between rounds,
you would do your assessment of who won.
They didn't like it.
I liked your,
I liked,
I really let the commission didn't like it because Eddie's,
Eddie would have a rationalization.
He would have a voice,
he'd have to be,
he could be speakers mind just like Harold [inaudible].
I think it makes it exciting for people because Eddie had it broken down.
I watched him do it.
He sat next to me during the fights.
He,
I mean he was fucking dilligent his shit and he made his own system instead of
falling instead of just like looking at the scorecard and trying to figure it
out.
Eddie had a whole breakdown of like kicks,
takedown,
shorthand and shorthand.
Everything had two guys and I'd look at the fight and go,
kick,
punch,
take down,
attempt left knee and then after that round they're giving me 30 seconds to make
my assessment.
I got to go back and review.
If you don't write it down like that,
you don't remember.
You don't remember shit.
Yeah.
You to go back and look at it.
So now I go,
I reviewed her that he landed two punches there.
This guy landed a big knee.
Which one was more subtle and then Bam.
I have something to look at when I'm so a lot to look at it.
So I'd much rather have that than have these three fucking square's judging my
fight.
Ridiculous.
Ridiculous,
ridiculous.
Still to this sport.
I think it's still important to have no,
those schlubs judging what's important.
What's wrong with it?
I think so.
Are you drunk?
It's gone.
You got to listen.
Listen,
Sam as stars and you don't think you don't think,
uh,
if you were running the casinos and you'll run and all that shit,
all the bedding,
you don't think that it's good to have ball guys that judges good to blame the
stupid judge like kit,
stupid judge.
No corruption and casino.
It's talking about it as me.
He's going into corruption and this is another level.
He can't help it.
I was running the casinos.
I would want schlubs in there so that if,
if we looked at the numbers and we're like,
shit,
we need this decision or that decision.
Brian talked to him.
I want to say,
let me,
let me tell you this.
Let me tell you this.
No,
seriously,
I've had a judge tell me I'm not gonna say his name and somewhere else.
I've mentioned his name,
but I'm not gonna mention his name tonight.
A judge,
a very popular,
popular UFC judge has told me to it.
I'll say it's judge Judy.
Judge Judy told me that three separate occasions on three separate occasions,
he wrote down a score for one fighter and then when Bruce Buffer Reddit,
it was for the other guy three different times.
This guy told me to my face three different times.
He's very funny to me.
Never want to fight against Eddie.
He might be an idiot and I don't know.
He might be looking for a fall guy as the commission being the same.
That's what I would say judging.
That's what I would do if I was running the casinos.
Let's watch the fight we were about to watch.
We don't want to get fucking killed here.
These are just my crazy assumptions.
They're both 35 answering story about big foot Silva.
When Shane,
he was like four no five [inaudible] a lead XC had a big foot Silva's contract.
They offered chain and contract
to fight big foot Silva.
That fight would have been insane.
Kazoos uh,
Shane car one who's fucking prime?
Bigfoot silver in his prime.
They're supposed to fight,
but then the UFC offered Shane.
So then Shane went to the UFC instead of finding bigfoot.
So once,
when Shane was what looked like healthy men,
healthy human master of the universe.
Dude coming in at two 61 in this five,
by the way,
we're usually walking around at two 45 I believe.
No two seats.
A lot of weight.
He got pretty heavy like right after he fought Brock foot.
A little bit of acne on his back.
That's normal.
That's normal in Brazil.
It's hot down there
are sold.
It's hot down there in are really hot right now.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Is there air conditioning was from the 50 [inaudible] 92 think Maria Amazon.
He's pissed at the ring girls for ripping off the shit.
For sure.
He's,
he's assigning the Bagpipe,
pulls him in the back.
He's,
that's his baby's Pavey.
He's telling them to do that.
He's franchising marking his territory.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm interested when they do,
the heart guys know there's a lot of beef in this ring or this octagon right
now.
I think when he got mad,
he lost a lot of it's speed,
man.
He lost a lot of,
it's heavy,
heavy.
After Brock beat the brakes off mount of half guard when you pound them out and
half guard.
Then he started doing this.
Powerlifting got all big,
which wasn't good.
The age of the big,
big heavyweights gone.
How big are you?
Uh,
two 40.
Wow.
That's pretty bad.
Is it 250 pounds?
What's 25 pounds lighter than the weight?
Can we get the king at to two oh five you had to?
Yes.
You're thinking about it maybe why I say yes.
Look at that.
Hey,
if you can make it,
that's your spot.
If you can make it that your spot.
If you can't make it that simple.
Who knows?
Don't want to get into it.
Hey,
don't let Joe turned into me
at two oh five the other bits.
I'll have a big foot please.
You want big foot,
big foot.
I got friends.
You got to action.
I'll take the American because I'm American.
Yeah,
me too.
Fuck yeah.
Big bodies not looking great.
Come on Frankie.
Frank.
Bigfoot looks very angry,
so gets a hell of a target though.
That head,
Chin hot move.
That Shannon's a hell of a target.
Who Frank looks good man.
Yeah,
like under his feet there.
Well that's what he needs,
man.
That's what he needs at this point in his life.
You need some speed.
I would love if frank submitted them.
Ooh,
big foot said he's uh,
looking for redemption for his boy.
Knows a black belt,
right?
Yes.
Never been submitted ever in this.
And even in the game he's got what he says.
Good fucking man.
It's impossible.
Never been submitted.
That combination,
he lands around over him.
There was one of the best ever that you haven't seen a Kale like that since Phil
Baroni Kale.
Dave Manet,
everyone.
He pinned him up against the cage.
Yeah.
Dang.
Dang,
Like one of the greatest,
his hand combination kof field we're on.
He's just number one in my opinion.
That combination was just like video game named Mark Cord versus
Tyron Woodley.
That's my favorite.
Ooh,
but that was elbows.
You know what I mean?
Still is nasty.
I didn't believe.
Yeah,
he didn't guess.
Oh look good.
Right hand,
right hand by Frank.
Oh,
looking fast,
man.
He looks much fast than they just looked recently.
Frank lives light on his feet.
He's moving around a lot.
He's moving around like,
man.
Yeah,
well that's what he needs,
man.
That's what he was holding him back.
He was to plotting and he got two big,
big foot always has to worry about getting hit.
Man.
He knows his chin is just not that good anymore.
When our Lawsky clipped him with at one point,
I mean it didn't,
but before that eight punches from the hardest puncher ever.
Really in the USA when he was Jews to the titty.
Either way though,
Brian,
but that affects you.
I guarantee you.
That affects you.
It has to.
It just only makes sense that it does.
How ironic.
Isn't it weird?
His arms look really skinny on.
Oh yeah.
Hey man,
I'm going crazy.
No,
they don't look,
I mean,
they don't look big at all.
They look like Brian Collins arms on a big body
like coil vipers.
The bones underneath them.
I like telephone poles just to make [inaudible] it's over.
It's over right there
still Donesville dance and you'll look good,
right?
The tank.
I don't have any American currency.
What did he say,
man?
What did he just say?
He just said something.
Damn,
that's a big cut.
Big Foot just squirted when he stood up.
[inaudible]
son,
you know?
That's why I bet on him and that's why I want a dollar from John Wayne Park
because I just don't feel like this dude can take a punch anymore.
I don't like the way he went down against our LAUSC.
It looked crazy like you went down and I was like,
whoa.
You think it's a lack of TRT?
I think I did it for sure.
If I think it's a number look at this.
That's a nice combination,
man.
A Jab left hook.
That's some fucking buster Douglas Shit.
Hell yeah.
Let do this in Brazil.
Bone is lepto.
Beautiful Man.
I'm sorry.
That is a beautiful combination
for sure.
Stop the food that,
oh dude,
he's dead.
You don't really see Frank Mir grounding pounding,
but Goddamn,
he has vicious crime.
Dude.
That was man.
You can do it all.
That was fucking Nice,
dude.
This is the Frank Mir of old.
This is a really good look and Frank Mir here.
Ooh,
I'm impressed.
Wow.
That is fucking ferocious through town for frank,
man.
I'm impressed.
Good for him.
Thank you for the dollar,
frank.
Yeah.
What does he say?
Does he think he's talking to Brock Lesnar?
I'm back now.
You said something like,
you know,
I don't know what he said.
I hope not.
What?
He's not talking to Prague.
Well,
that fight is over,
so the fights are over.
Let's rewind it and see if we could figure out what the fuck he said.
Can we rewind it Jamie?
We got a remote.
Maybe he'll read.
Say it in the post interview right here though,
right?
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe.
that's a good point.
We should let him say it.
Yeah,
maybe I can read those guys.
Well that's good news.
Yeah.
Bright Red Lipstick for the marinas.
Yeah,
I did.
Let's see what he says.
He goes,
boom,
boom.
Here it goes.
I watched you this.
So was he trying to do,
he told her I love you baby.
Don't talk.
Why would you talk?
That's the only thing we were waiting for.
Sorry Buddy.
I love you babe.
No biggest inspiration.
Oh yeah,
it wasn't DC.
Daddy's making the money.
I think something along those lines and get some money.
That was bringing the bill.
Yeah,
it's making that money.
I love you baby.
Daddy's making that money.
There you go.
Wow.
That's the best thing he could could've said.
You Look God Damn Good Fucking Jab,
left hook combination was very pretty.
What do you do if your big foot retire?
Damn for him and keeping him apprised.
Yeah.
I don't think he can fight without testosterone.
This is what I think it all the people that were on TRT,
that guy has the most legitimate reason to be on it.
He had a god damn cancer of his pituitary gland.
I mean,
look at that.
That's a beautiful comment,
but if you have to have that to fight,
don't fight.
You're right.
Fuck that noise.
I don't give a fuck what she got.
Boom.
You're right.
If you have to be juice to the gills to compete,
how about you don't do it?
How would you go find something else?
But I think is his natural testosterone is absurdly low because of the fact that
he had a tumor on his butt tour.
Derek Lam and his coaches were talking about when they eliminated a
testosterone,
like how bad it is for him.
Cool.
You're right.
Otherwise,
let me do it.
You're right.
Whatever you're taking,
I get to do it.
I think it was legal.
Would you do it?
I'll say yes for him.
My client will not speak loud it himself.
It's a little bit right.
Creamy just for recovery.
Right.
And he looked at me and we'll answer your questions or Joe Rogan,
please look at me.
Eddie
saw.
I'm saying,
that's all I'm saying.
I really liked you.
What you said the other day about the um,
there isn't any negatives.
Just taking it.
Yeah.
I thought that was a really good read.
It's uh,
it's tough man.
But with these new penalties that Dana White's talking about doing,
if they actually do it,
the two to four years suspension guys are,
yeah,
they're not going to risk it as much,
I don't think.
Yeah.
I think it's the only way to go because when bigfoot got done,
then he's first fight back is for main of the main event in Brazil.
What did you guys think when it's,
for me a and John Jones both had those really weird tests.
Like they tested them afterwards and they both had a really low testosterone to
epitestosterone level.
What are you doing here?
What's going on here?
No,
you guys talk about,
you know,
something.
I don't know anything positive.
I promise.
I don't know anything.
Okay.
All right,
well I shouldn't even ask you right now though,
isn't true from from
that when your testosterone is very low like that,
chances are you were,
you introduced.
That's what Victor Conte was saying,
but I think that's irresponsible to say unless you're,
you're testing these guys all the time.
It could be that there were,
bro,
I heard a bunch of different variables.
One of them that could be their,
their body was broken down because they're exhausted from training so much and
that their testosterone was low because they caught him in mid camp.
That could be the case.
It could be that they were both overtrained,
which is more likely than not if you want to look at it like,
but I don't know.
See,
I'm an idiot.
I don't understand those tests enough to tell you.
If that would cause someone to have a low testosterone to epitestosterone ratio.
We would have to bring in like Mark Gordon.
We have to bring in an endocrinologist to explain and you'd also have to do more
than one test.
And based off that,
that's why I don't come.
And I mean,
I don't know those guys who the fuck knows,
but I know they uh,
they had like a legit guy doctor read the thing.
It was like there's no way their levels should be that low.
Yeah,
but they don't know what's going on.
Maybe.
Maybe D D C in John's levels have always been low.
Let's crank the volume up so he could hear what Frank Mir also say.
Huge win for French.
Huge.
And not only that,
but looked fucking great man.
It's cool to see these guys.
Your bodybuilding days.
What was the stove situation?
Hold on.
Let's hear this.
Let's say this.
I work on my lats.
Mosley.
Wow.
No heavyweight is much higher than him.
I could've swore fracking in English.
She said to heal my body.
I got to of some good trainers and break brown.
How about Ricky?
Lindale right behind you looking all angry face.
There we go.
Obviously it's a three switch to right.
You switched.
I didn't even notice that.
God,
I didn't either.
That was such a beautiful combination.
Ma'Am.
I only move three inches to the beautiful.
Beautiful.
Especially with those little gloves.
Right.
Big Difference.
How much adjustment do you have to make defensively,
John,
when you're working with guys,
we,
I'm sure you've trained with MMA fighters and teaching them Moitai how much of
a,
an adjustment you have to make because they have less coverage defensively
because of the smaller gloves.
Yeah.
It wasn't until I started wearing them for getting ready for the fight that I
really appreciated how different it is.
It was like starting all over again.
Once I put the little ones on,
I thought I knew how to fight and you thought and you had a punch until I wore
them,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I'm not punching.
I'm not punching on my knuckles.
I'm using my pinky and before I could close my eyes and hit the pads and their
problem and now I can't hit the pad in the same spot twice.
Even when I'm fully concentrating.
It's so difficult.
It's so hard.
Wow.
That's interesting man.
Yeah.
But,
um,
yeah,
completely different stuff from our hooks in Verena idea.
Great idea.
Kickboxing with MMA gloves in a [inaudible] it's pretty much MMA,
but with no ground because you're still at the knees.
Just do what the elbows,
you still got the,
the takedowns.
There's nothing changes and you get,
do you find guys press guys are up against the cage and blast him with elbows
and knees the body and hold them there and yeah,
we'll,
what I found with my shows is say it,
I have 10 fights,
majority this.
Usually there will be seven go the distance because the guys are fighting
smarter as well because they know that they can't stand in the pocket and trade
anymore because the gloves are so small.
They're bringing a better a game now.
I noticed that after the fight,
you can't touch the top of your head if we're about four or five days,
you can't put your sunglasses on because your head's like a golf ball.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
They're getting hit 50 to a hundred times a fight.
Yeah.
Easily.
Tone.
Hey,
50 Shung.
Remember when you described a fight that you had when you were in high school,
like it was two punches that you,
you talked about how you landed two punches,
put your friends like bitch you didn't land.
It was like two or three,
three if he didn't believe that shit like,
but in MMA fights like land 50 to a hundred solid,
he imagined describing that fight to somebody because you always described your
fight ride.
He tried to take me down,
then I punched him and then the PE teacher pulled us off trying to describe a
fight with 50 punches cause somebody you can't remember it had to take him
through the whole thing.
There's a lot of guys that have to watch fights after they're over just to see
what happened to them.
They don't even remember.
I
remember what happened.
How many times have I interviewed fighters and they'll be honest like after the
second round,
I have no idea what happened.
I don't know.
That just woke up and it was the fifth round.
You know that's happened so many times man,
so much.
Most fights,
like if you asked me like go and have in the second round,
I can't tell you third round like Cro,
cop and I don't remember a lot from it.
And I just remember being in zone.
What was interesting about the Travis Brown fight,
I was rocked when,
uh,
I went for a takedown and he wizard I in his hip,
landed on my head into the octagon and I remember watching it and you're like,
oh,
I don't remember any of this after this.
And I remember,
I just remember watching like,
Dang,
like the first time I've ever seen you were just,
I was more,
bell was a mess.
Yeah.
I messed up just from his hip check that.
Well,
the problem from the Mat.
Yeah.
When you see a guy like George Saint Pierre,
that was like the greatest of all time.
And now,
you know,
since he didn't test positive,
a lot of people are saying he's the greatest of all time.
100% person.
Oh,
he needs to understand how works.
Yeah.
Well I see that argument.
It's a very logical argument,
but when you look at the numbers of times that he was hit,
they,
we did a thing after his career was over.
It was over 800 times.
So Craig just in the octagon.
Yeah.
Not Train on changes and not in TK.
Oh,
and the other organizations he fought for before he came to the UFC.
And you know what a lot of it was the last few fights,
a lot of it,
you got to hit more in
his last like four fights and all of his other fights.
It's amazing man.
Let's watch this again man.
God Damn Frank Mir look good even before that.
Like light on his feet too.
That is beautiful.
I'm off man.
Really helped them.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Maybe that switching standards to that is back to Orthodox.
That is tremendous right there.
Look at that.
That's beautiful technique.
He's such a smart dude.
Frank Mir is,
he's an interesting character.
Have you ever heard of misunderstood?
Have you heard him commentating?
When did wcs and he was really,
really good man.
Well when he said he wanted to kill Brock Lesnar,
be the first guy to kill him.
That's when they pulled them off commentary.
Yeah.
You kind of going a half day.
Nobody remembers that shit anymore.
He's good.
Put them back in.
Yeah.
Oh he's the,
he's one of the best.
I wish you would do more of it.
Well he's very smart man.
He's very articulate.
He reads a lot of books.
You know,
he's an interesting dude that Frank Mir.
I liked that.
I like when a guy takes a little time off,
it takes a deep breath.
Reassesses gets back kid.
Sometimes dudes run,
they run on all these injuries and they just fucking keep just trying to tape
this up and patch that up and stretch through this and they don't just take that
time to recuperate.
You know what's crazy is Baca.
When MMA first start exploring the UFC first art exploding people.
It's like,
man,
how does it feel that you have huge,
I would always say cause coming from being at such a big football fan,
I thought well the UFC really isn't that huge yet until we start seeing these
like football type NFL,
the day type shows like a nightly NMA show.
We haven't stayed like 10 years ago.
We hadn't seen it now.
How crazy is it?
W We,
we see it all the time.
Like right now we're watching and,
and Brian stands in a suit and Dominick Cruz is in a suit and they're prime time
nationwide on these major networks and now they're the guys that I'm used to
seeing like a Lt,
you know,
do that kind of stuff.
Or,
or Tony Serra Goose.
So you know what I mean?
Being ex ex players now transitioning into broadcasting and you're seeing that
in MMA now.
All these ex MMA fighters or,
or,
or even current ones,
really their transit,
they're putting the suits on and they're on Fox.
It's nuts.
It's crazy.
Look at Brian Stan,
he's on this is,
you're used to seeing him like some college basketball show right now.
Dan also,
those football doesn't go it.
He does a sideline Fullerton college for Fox.
Uh,
I'm Pr,
don't quote me on that,
but he does college football.
I think he's really good.
No,
he's actually really,
really good.
Brian.
Stan is,
is like natural.
He's my favorite lunch.
Shouldn't pick a favorite guys dude.
My job
cause he's great and I want to be rude to the other guys.
Do it.
I'll tell you right now,
Jimmy Smits my favorite.
How about that?
It been work for the UFC.
He's my friend Jimmy Smith is doing boxing now for spiking fucking great.
Jimmy Smits a bad motherfucker.
He's a cool dude too.
Is a good dude.
Yeah.
You know,
we're supposed to be like rivals or some shit.
We're,
we're good.
He's the nicest guy.
He's legit.
Loves fighting me.
And that guy have sat down with no one around and talked fighting for hours.
He loves fighting gloves,
loves MMA,
loves boxing because you have a background.
He was a PR problem and may fighter fought for a while.
Um,
he'd be just be chasing chambers.
He,
he looked him,
he's blackballing Jujitsu.
He's legit.
He was,
he was on that show.
Five request traveled around.
I mean,
yeah.
Yeah,
that's how I know him from the show.
He's a legit martial arts.
A great commentator.
Yeah.
But he's a good dude.
He takes a lot of heat because we're both bald and they think that he's copying
me but really are copied him first.
Yeah.
I shaved my head second.
He shaved his first night.
He was copying,
you know,
like easy bro.
I get you want to be row Hoodie so off copying him.
He's good man.
Yeah.
He never says anything.
I like,
I'll go watch this guy's crazy.
The guys will say things and you go,
um,
I don't know.
I don't think that's right.
You know,
like there's,
there's guys that,
you know,
you hear him and other organizations,
so you go,
is this all you had?
This is the only guy that can,
they don't know what's going on,
man.
Guys,
we'll call kicks,
you know,
Spinning Hook,
kick to the leg.
Like that was not what you just saw.
Like,
you don't even know.
Like imagine if a head kick,
hey take 10 leg.
But we got to the point now,
especially with all the UFC shows where they got,
they got professional guys and then guys that can really do the job.
Like Jon Anik,
he's professional,
he's excellent,
but he's a sports guy.
He calls things wrong because the guys who don't train,
I mean I think Anik might train a little bit,
but they just didn't call anything.
Like technically the Christian called positions and they certainly shouldn't
call transitions or potential bats because they know they're going to miss some
stuff.
You know why they're doing that.
They try to look down to chill.
Some guys do it because they try to pretend that they know what they're doing.
And I don't mean John,
I mean I'm really talking to most about guys and the be leaks.
You know,
John doesn't really do that,
but guys who do do it,
it's annoying because like I know what you're doing.
You're just trying to let everybody know your knowledge.
Well,
this is what happened.
Is it when MMA first,
uh,
started like king of the cage,
for instance,
when I got thrown into the commentator spot,
the producers didn't even know the difference between a play by play and a color
guy.
Most people don't really know,
they just hear two people talking.
But if you really look into it,
oh there's like a newscaster guy who's holding it all together and then a color
guy who gets asked questions and terms in whenever there's a professional guy
and a guy that just chimes in.
And I had to learn that the hard way,
man.
And what ended up happening is in the beginning that wasn't professional
broadcasters to play the field that play by play spot.
So they would just take anybody and anybody that would throw in there would do
color too.
He would be doing play by play and color so that guys like Mike Goldberg would
see this and go,
you know what,
these guys,
these other guys are doing play by play and a little color.
So my Goldberg,
you know,
he's trained kickboxing and he think when he sees it,
he calls it right.
He calls the t because some stuff and people get angry.
But you know Gilbert,
Dick Nfl.
Yeah.
I love gold.
He how dare
you not even get through the l before you got your fucking shitting smile
because he got fired.
He started arguing with people on Twitter.
People were saying he fucked up a couple of things and one of them was two guys
at the same name.
Right?
They said the same number of different name Adam.
One guy like he called one receiver that the same number and the same name?
No,
no,
no.
Like a receiver for another team.
You gotta make stop.
He called one team,
like the Detroit lions.
Wait a minute.
This was a lot of freshmen.
I love Mike.
Was this his first NFL game?
Yes.
And then he got fired.
He got online.
You don't even know what we're talking about it all the time on your show.
Yes,
it does it.
And there's only the two of you.
I've seen it.
He will be,
he'll be talking to you about something and you'll say something.
Well No,
you all are talking about that first one.
I was Mike Goldberg Vendor.
You were like,
I was like,
I think talking about the rest of the,
why would they're talking about commentators,
would they talk about little,
I think my goal,
but it is the best play by play guy.
A hundred percent 100% muy Thai references and all that stuff.
I don't care about that shit.
I understand it.
My Goal Goldberg working with them for eight years,
nobody studies and prepares us ladies,
man,
he's the only guy in the meetings and these UFC meetings.
He's got his laptop out and he's got every,
he's ready to go.
He's on top of everything.
He rehearses all night in his room.
That guy is mega,
super ultra profession.
He and I have really good chemistry too.
I really do love that dude.
We've been working together for a long time and he's seriously one on one as a
friend.
That guy's one of the sweetest guys,
if not the sweetest guy I've ever met.
Such a nice,
cool to everybody.
Nice to everybody.
He's not a dick at all.
That guy's awesome.
I love my thinking would have kept the NFL Gig.
If he didn't get on Twitter and he was like defending himself,
he'd be fine.
Cause let's say you messed up cause that's a lot to take on that I wasn't
thinking about the impact or the reach.
You know like you get on Twitter,
you know you're,
you're shitting on your followers that are calling you a loser.
Why don't you put on the headphones and get back there?
Maybe how old to drink.
But I've always told them,
we've had those conversations about,
you know,
how to deal with assholes on Twitter.
Mike,
you don't,
don't deal with,
we deal with them.
Why would you deal with them?
Why you vent,
let them enter into your life.
Just go more in this man.
And by the way,
the ones that hurt distinct ones that actually sting,
they're probably telling you some shit that you could use to hear and you hear
that and then correct your game so that it doesn't ever possibly make any sense.
So that any criticism they have that's related to what they were talking about,
it's illogical.
Right?
It doesn't make any sense at all.
You know,
if someone tells me,
you know,
like a,
you're,
you're doing commentary,
you don't know what the fuck is going on.
When the fight goes to the ground,
I'll go,
ha ha,
that's,
that's adorable.
I'm not going to fight with them.
You don't want to acknowledge it.
You acknowledge them.
People go,
Ooh,
Joe Rogan or Bryan County acknowledged this negative stuff.
So then more than exactly monsters come out.
I think we're running out of time here.
How much time we got.
That's it.
It's over three hours and don kids brand and motherfucking job can be reached on
Twitter.
You can watch and listen to the fighter and the kid where he relentlessly
corrects Brian
all the time as I'm fine.
Often the number one sports podcast in America because the rest of the country
is filled with bullshit and I got a song to capitalizing on a nice soft spot in
the industry
and to his right.
Of course,
the great John Wayne Parr who will be on my podcast tomorrow at noon.
We will talk about his extensive Moitai career,
which is unparalleled.
One of the,
for real man.
You're one of the greats.
This is a,
I'm going to be an awesome treat.
We've got to get some training into think Brendan Schaub wants to train with us
too,
and went to come down and learn some other time on.
When is that?
Tomorrow before.
What are you doing,
bitch?
You got some fucking shitty calm you have to do.
I know what time,
what time you gotta do Eliza,
I think.
Hey,
let's talk.
Let's talk later.
This is,
this thing's over Eddie Bravo.
You can reach Eddie Bravo at Eddie Bravo on Twitter.
10th Planet J j.com the new video that you showed me that was fucking
unbelievable and amazing.
10 Planet commercial that Bobby Ray's Zack produced.
How could they get it?
You just go to youtube and punch in 10th Planet Jiu Jitsu Commercial,
2015 at that time,
completely.
100% of the time.
It's over.
We're over three minute,
three hours.
CanNot everybody.
We'll see you soon.